Three,
two,
one.
Hello Mike.
Hey.
Hello.
Pat.
Pat,
pat.
Tell us Panatella.
So one,
one word,
Roseanne,
or like Godzilla.
Okay,
cool.
All right dude.
Well nice to meet you guys.
I've met you before,
but nice to meet you.
Um,
for people who don't know,
let's just give them right off the bat.
Your story would happen to you.
How you got in trouble in Canada for a
joke.
Real trouble.
I got,
I'm find $42,000
a Canadian or American Canadian,
uh,
which was,
like now close to 42,000
American reference.
It was,
um,
yeah,
let's say like 38,000
American.
And uh,
there's a thing in Canada called the
human rights commission that every
province has one of those.
I had a joke about,
I'm a little boy that was famous.
He was a singer.
He was a disabled boy.
And the,
the joke,
it wasn't even that mean it was just a
little kid that was disabled and he was
uh,
he was Kinda like a make a wish
foundation type kid.
And he was famous in Canada.
He was famous in French Canada.
He had sang for the pope and the joke
was like,
I was super happy for him at first it's
a little deaf boy.
He's dying.
He,
his dream was to sync for the pope and
then he became like a,
like front page news on a,
you know,
everywhere in Montreal.
And then he,
he got a record deal and then he sang
for the Canadians.
Then he came out with a book and then at
the end I was like,
why isn't he dead yet?
Like,
wasn't he supposed to die?
That's just the basic stuff.
Like he's a little dark joke.
Yeah.
Like,
it's what I do is dark humor.
Like I'm not,
I'm not Ray Romano.
Right.
So I did that joke and uh,
in never did that joke on TV.
Did that joke in a special.
The Dea didn't air on TV.
I cut a couple of things out for TV.
But uh,
I,
I get a letter from the human rights
people saying you owe 80.
First it was they wanted 82,000
for the joke.
They were like,
we listened to the joke.
We think that this boy's family deserves
82,000
[inaudible] of this joke.
What a weird number.
And I thought I thought they were like
this how fucking stupid I am.
When I got the letter and I saw human
rights commission,
I thought I was getting an award or a
prize or something because I,
I do,
I do a lot of benefits and stuff.
But for,
I raised money for disabled people.
So I was like,
fuck,
it's a bad time.
They recognize me as a good dude.
So I read this and then I called my
manager and I'm like,
fuck,
they want 80,000.
And we were like,
okay,
let's just get the best lawyer we can.
So I found the best lawyer in Canada,
uh,
that does a free speech stuff.
Met Him and he told me the reason why it
was $80,000,
$80,000
is a weird number.
Like if they ask a 2 million,
you're going to fight it,
but 80,000
is big enough to kind of scare you but
not enough to really scare you.
You'll go like,
look,
okay,
can I give you a 40 and then they'll go,
give me a few questions.
So this bit you said you cut it from the
special.
Right.
So how do they know about it?
Uh,
it was,
um,
I did this interview on TV and the um,
the reporter talked about the bit he had
never seen the bit.
Oh,
so how did he know about someone told
them about the bed,
but the bed was in the special,
the specialist.
So it was on the Internet.
So you could watch it.
Yeah,
you could watch it on the Internet and
this special had been in movie theaters
in Canada.
It's just when we sold it on TV,
this in French was in French.
That's what I was weird.
Whenever people were talking about the
bit they were like,
it was,
especially in Canada and in England
where it's very left leaning.
People were talking shit about the bit
and I was like,
you,
you can't even understand that joke.
That's in a language.
You don't speak about a person you don't
know.
So the people almost made it look like I
just picked this random disabled boy and
I was making fun of his disability,
but I was making fun of the fact that he
had become famous because everyone
thought he was dying and then he didn't
die,
which is a,
you know,
for him it's a dark joke.
It's all.
It is.
Not even that particularly mean.
No,
it's a question really.
You're not saying,
hey,
why don't you die?
I spent money.
You little fuck yeah.
And say that.
No.
You said how come he's alive?
Yeah,
exactly.
And when I did the thing for TV,
I cut a couple things out that I thought
could get me in trouble because I
figured,
you know,
when you put out a special and people
pay for the special,
you should be allowed.
And I still think this and this.
I think everyone should think this way
if it like if you put out a special,
you should be allowed to say whatever
the fuck you want to say.
But if you sell your special to like CBS
or ABC,
then of course they're going to cut shit
out of course.
But like your,
your last special on Netflix.
It'd be crazy if netflix had looked joe,
we fucking loved your special but this,
you got to cut this out.
You've got to cut this into netflix
credit.
That's one of the reasons why they're so
amazing.
They,
they don't give you hardly any input at
all.
Those there go,
hey,
we really liked it.
It's like they don't do anything.
Yeah,
they uh,
you know,
I had some controversial shit and this
one in my last one,
they just let it go.
That's much appreciated.
Yeah.
I was really happy when I saw your last
special.
I thought it was the perfect thing to,
to come back from a Nanette,
like the,
the gatsby special.
It's an important special,
but it's not funny and it's like,
it's almost,
you know what it is,
it's her art,
right?
The problem is we're putting it in this
box,
right?
You're saying that standup comedy.
But if you do something and it has some
laughs in it and then it goes on this,
this by this journey,
biographical journey of your life and
your ubs observations and you,
you say it in a way that's meaningful
and people still enjoy it,
but it's not funny anymore.
It's still I,
a lot
of comics didn't like it.
A lot of columns got upset and I was
like,
okay,
I get,
I get why you would say it's not comedy,
but I don't get why you would get upset.
Because obviously people like it.
Like I don't get upset if people like
certain books or certain songs that like
the.
I have a good friend who likes fish,
you know?
I mean I don't hate fish,
but it's not my cup of tea.
Right.
It's not a bad.
That makes me upset that your friend,
your friend likes fit.
He said Jamie,
Jamie,
Jamie and I have nothing against fish.
I just,
maybe I need to listen to it.
Hi.
Maybe I need.
Jamie says no js.
It's not jamie like that.
That Hannah gatsby special.
Like I really wanted to watch it because
I didn't want to be some guy that
listened to three minutes said,
fuck you.
So I did listen to it and I do get why
it.
It's in,
it's an important special and I think
it's good for what it is,
but I,
I didn't like the fact that people were
saying this is comedy in time.
Came out with the list,
the most hilarious specials and that was
number one at a time when it's like a
diversity Olympia toward told thing is
it's all very diverse.
There's some funny people on it,
no doubt,
but you can still like these lists.
First of all,
these lists are always weird because
especially when it's someone's
subjective opinion and there's nothing
wrong with that,
but it like,
who the fuck are you?
Like,
who's this?
Who's this person?
I would like to see Chris Rock's list of
top 10 comedians or top 10 comedy
specials or someone like that.
Someone who's who I know who they are.
I understand their thought process.
Maybe this person is a famous writer.
I don't know that.
I don't know if they're famous
journalist.
I like to see like Matt Tie ebs,
like top 10 movies,
but it's like a certain tea gets to
these top 10 things and you're like,
who sits here?
This is all so subjective.
It's so weird.
And the like,
the Nanette thing is,
um,
I need to watch it.
I've only watched parts of it,
um,
but that my reaction to it was my
reaction to everybody else's reaction.
So I'm like,
what is going on here?
Either it's the most amazing thing ever
or some sort of an affront to comedy,
you know?
And either it gets a bit of both because
I think it is like,
it's,
it's like a lot of people were saying
it's like a Ted talk and I think it kind
of is.
It's a funny Ted talk.
Nothing wrong with that,
right?
There's nothing.
I mean this is my point on all this.
It's like why do we need these sort of
parameters that comedy has to stay in
before we accept it because it doesn't
have to be your kind of shit for it to
be something that people enjoy.
Obviously someone enjoys it.
There's a lot of people enjoying it
because it's not.
There's some of those.
When they make those lists,
were you like,
let's include this person,
let's include that.
We've got to make sure we have x amount
of women and x amount.
You could see there's almost like
there's a thought process behind
creating these lists,
but some of those people will appear on
those lists over and over and over
again.
So that means to me,
for sure.
Somebody loves that special that's
special is like number one on so many
people's lists,
not just number two or number three.
It's number one.
A lot of people's lists,
so someone's enjoying it.
So like,
what do I give a shit?
What does anybody give a shit?
Was my reaction is my reaction to these
comics that are like upset?
I'm like,
but why?
But why are I remember why I remember
why they got mad.
It wasn't because they were saying it's
the number one special is because she
went on an interview I think in
Australia and said,
if you're a comedian who only cares
about making people laugh,
then you should stop doing comedy.
You shouldn't be in show business,
they shouldn't see you publicly,
you should give a message.
Right.
But I disagree with that strongly,
but from her perspective,
what she's trying to do,
it's like someone who's really into rock
and roll that like,
fuck rap,
music,
rock and roll,
you know,
that's what they're saying.
I mean,
that's what she's saying.
She's doing it in like a comedic form.
She's like,
if you're only in a comedy that makes
people laugh,
fuck you.
Kinda.
Yeah,
you're,
I'm in the deep comedy bitch.
I mean,
there's nothing wrong with one of my
favorite all time standards for sure is
Mitch Hedberg and Mitch Hedberg had all
nonsequitors.
Nothing was.
There's no deep meaning to any of it
all.
It was like super silly and still to
this day like,
especially if I'm in traffic,
I'll listen to that shit because it's
just so silly,
you know?
He's fucking.
It was amazing,
but it's just that his,
his expression and everybody's
expression is going to be different and
this is something I've figured out over
the course of my.
I mean,
I didn't get it right all the time when
I was young.
I was like,
you know,
I,
I hated people that didn't swear and I
was like,
there's no way you talk like that for
real.
There's no way you talk like that for
But then after awhile I was like,
why do I care?
Do some of the best ever.
Don't swear like Jerry Seinfeld.
He doesn't swear.
So one of the best comedians of all time
is,
it's not even a subjective question or
an opinion like you,
you,
everybody knows he's one of the best.
However,
if you have 100 comedians that,
to the best ever,
Jerry Seinfeld's none the,
your that lists bullshit.
Brian Regan hilarious.
Doesn't swear it off.
You know,
like there's a lot of great comics who
just have their thing.
Like there's,
there's comics that have puppets that
are really funny.
Like you just because you have a puppet,
it doesn't mean you're not really funny.
But for a lot of comics,
for Qms,
go to papa.
Yeah,
it's weird.
I'm not there yet.
I just felt like everything else I was
on Bart.
I was like,
do you ever say auto and George?
Yeah,
George.
But,
but that was almost making fun of the
whole thing,
but the end that I fucking love that
people would get mad at him because his
lips moved to fucking move bro.
He wasn't even trying to hide it.
It was just funny.
You know,
there was a,
there's been a few really fun a puppet
acts,
you know?
Um,
I mean,
who gives a shit?
Do whatever the fuck you like,
you know,
I think that's a thing though when
you're in your twenties that anything
that isn't what you do are you like,
is garbage,
right?
Yeah.
Because I remember I was like that too,
like a plus.
Like that was I think a,
uh,
thing about being in your twenties in
the nineties because we had just had,
you know,
Kennison and,
and you know,
uh,
like Bill Hicks and so,
so if,
if you were doing like a,
like,
like Jeff Foxworthy were,
we were judging you but we shouldn't
like,
yeah,
who gives a shit?
Yeah.
Jeff foxworthy parameters.
Like the nicest guy in the history of
the world.
Yeah.
He looks nice.
I'd never met him.
Larry the cable guy's nice as fuck.
He's super sweet and he got super judged
too hard.
People went hard on him.
Dave crossroad a crazy letter to him.
Like a letter from Dave,
the desk of days cross.
It was free.
It was like tongue in cheek,
but it's.
The idea was that he was somehow or
another promoting racism.
I think that was what people said.
He's doing a character.
His real name's Dan Whitney.
His character is really dumb guy who
doesn't have sleeves,
who's fucking hilarious and it's good
character.
His character isn't racist,
the racist,
but you know,
there's like these lands I looked,
there's once you run out of like really
high profile targets that are actually
racist,
then you have to like find things are
close to that.
I don't know what you're saying.
I don't like what you're saying there.
What are you saying about Asian people?
Like don't do it,
don't you fucking.
I mean there's some,
there's some things you could still get,
like there's some like absolute
realities that you,
you can say,
right?
Like you could say,
Asian people in generally have higher
iqs and they're better at math as a
fact,
Joe.
That's a solid fact,
you know,
but if it goes the other way,
if it's positive,
right,
you can always do it.
The thing about white people is we're
not as smart as Asians.
See,
I could say that because I'm white,
but if I was Asian and I was like,
white people are just not as smart.
Even though it's true like terms of Iq
tests and mathematics in particular,
they're just fucking smarter.
There's so,
so much smarter.
You know what they're doing in Harvard.
Yeah.
See this shit.
They're.
They're making it more difficult for
Asian students to get into Harvard.
There's a class action lawsuit because
they've actually raised the score levels
that Asians have to achieve because
there's so many of them.
Fast,
racist,
and that's actual racism.
Phrase this super racist,
fucking racist,
but you don't hear leftwing people,
progressive people calling out that kind
of racism because because of the way
many Asian cultures have sort of
structured their society,
people don't complain as much and they
work hard and they like fucking put
their nose to the grindstone and they
get going and this is part of their
culture and so when something like this
happens there,
they have to break out of those norms in
order to protest is really obvious
racism and because they really haven't
done that before,
they just sort of silently working hard.
Harvard just decided,
no,
it's too many of you.
You fucking smarty pants,
Asian folk.
So.
Well a few people have.
Jordan Peterson has.
Sam Harris has,
you know,
there's a few recognized public minds.
I would,
you know the word intellectual,
such a weird word,
right?
Public intellectuals,
but those guys are definitely public
intellectuals where they have these long
form discussions.
I don't remember watching on the
Internet.
They're doing these debates together.
Fascinating man.
It's really fascinating.
Especially they're just there
discussions about religion because
Jordan is fairly religious,
but the.
He's got a really interesting way of
putting it.
He says he,
he acts as if God is real,
not that he believes in God,
but that he acts as if God is real and
he finds great benefit to that,
which is very arguable.
Right.
And that Harris is like not buying it at
all and he's brilliant too.
So the two of them together,
it's like,
wow,
this is,
this is a fascinating.
It's like really cool high level
conversation and you get to sit in on.
The thing I like about Darren Peterson,
I've noticed whenever I watch his
interviews,
he,
he thinks like sometimes like if someone
asks them a question,
you'll see them stop and think to really
see where he's gone.
Whereas like a dumb guy like me,
I just started talking and I'm like,
ah,
I'll eventually out.
He knows exactly what he's saying,
you know,
especially in regards to like Marxist
history and things that he gets very
upset about.
You know,
he gets,
he's,
he's having these conversations like
literally on a daily basis.
So was going over a lot of these
grievances and a lot of the material he
talks about,
he's going over to a lot.
So he's got that shit bolted down and he
got in trouble too with the human rights
commission in Ontario.
Yeah.
He got in trouble because they were
going to force people to use compelled
pronouns and there were some weird
language that he didn't like about the
way they could enforce it or what they
were asking people to do.
And then it got to the point where we're
saying,
well,
we're talking about made up words now.
Like it gets to a certain point where
people get,
look,
people are fucking self-indulgent.
We all know it.
And,
and,
but there's also the other side of it
says,
well,
people also should be able to express
themselves as freely as you guys get to
do on stage.
Why can't they do that with their name
or their gender or you know,
whatever the fuck they want.
And why do you care if it's so simple to
just say whatever the fuck they want you
to say,
you know,
it's just a name,
right?
Xer or all those.
But Jordan was like there 78 different
ones.
Now we can't do this like this is,
this is chaos.
And I like,
I'm very pro trans,
like you can do whatever the fuck you
want to do,
but it's the same as like onstage,
I can do whatever the fuck I want to do
on state,
but that doesn't mean you have to come
see me.
And it's the same thing if you want to
be called Zur,
I don't even know what the fuck that is.
So I'm accidentally going to call you
her or him.
Yeah,
that can definitely happen.
And you can't get upset at that.
No one knows what the fuck is.
And plus like if you get it wrong,
it's an accident,
right?
There's a difference between you being
on stage because it was like a choice
with your life,
right?
You decided to be a comedian
is an argument there.
Right.
And then the other side is,
well they didn't have a choice.
They,
they,
they feel compelled,
like they actually are of the other
gender and they,
they,
their brain is wired like the other
gender and their body just isn't what
they're supposed to have and it's
fucking with their head.
Got It.
Okay.
I'm cool with that too.
You know,
like I don't.
It's fine.
As long as you're not interfering with
other people's lives because of your
choices.
Like if you're not,
you're not fucking with me.
I don't have to do anything.
I just have to call you.
She now okay.
Yeah,
as long as I know.
I'm uncomfortable.
I don't.
Why would you bully someone on purpose?
You know it's going to fuck with them.
His problem was that he didn't want it
to be compelled because they need to get
in trouble if you fuck up.
Exactly.
And this is,
this is what he's talking about.
He has no problem calling a male who
transitioned to female girl or she or
her,
but he's like,
you can't use these.
You can't compel me to use these made up
words.
Because at a certain point when these
things get rolling,
they become contests and they become
this battle.
It's an idea battle.
Which side are you on?
And they try to win.
It's one of the problems that I have
with police officers and even the court
system that what happens when you get a
prosecutor and a defense attorney is
there's a contest going on and these
guys,
they are involved in this contest
multiple times a week with a bunch of
different cases and they're moving
things around all the time,
but they're constantly trying to win.
This is what they're trying to do.
When a cop pulls you over and he,
he gets you for something,
he's trying to arrest you.
He's trying to win.
Like we were playing a game.
Now you know this is,
he's allowed to play this game and this
is what he's supposed to do and you
know,
he's got every right to do it.
So he's going to search your home and
it'll shoot your dog because you have
weed.
And this is where all this stuff comes
from.
It comes to these,
this insane justification for these
ridiculous axe comes from the fact that
you've been given a set of rules in
order to participate in this game,
but the game when it comes to like
things like compelled pronouns and when
it becomes too like pushing the envelope
further and further and further at a
certain point in time,
you can't say no you,
you can't make up a new language.
Okay?
Agreed.
Okay.
You can't make a new bill lang.
You know,
I can't.
I don't have to learn,
you know,
fucking Mikey language and PD language
and Tommy Lee.
So let's just agree on the words we use.
How many different new words do you
have?
Boiling down to one,
get back to me if you want to call it a
trans person or a queer person,
you want to call Missouri as everybody
agreeZ,
,
h e r,
Z,
that's a new thing.
I don't give a fuck,
but don't say I got to go to.
I'll go to jail or you can bring me in
front of a trial or some tribunals,
some fucking tribal council.
What are you going to do?
You're gonna Bang drums and decide if
I've uttered the wrong phrase,
but who are these guys to judge also,
because Mike didn't tell you,
but one of the judges on that tribunal
who was saying,
Oh,
you're a piece of shit for making fun of
a kid after that was found to have
kiddie porn.
He was some kind of child molester and
he was judging that he was too shitty to
a kid.
There were two people at the Human
Rights Commission
in Quebec.
The we're.
One of them was the president that had
to resign,
that he had paid off a 13 year old girl
like 15 years ago to not tell anyone
that he had had sex with her and then
another one,
I think he had had sex with a.
It was a six year old,
like it was fucking crazy,
but these motherfuckers.
That's what I hated.
These.
These people were telling me,
okay,
you're.
You did a joke onstage and that's all
your intent.
That's what people forget.
Oftentimes in my intent wasn't to hurt
this little kid.
My intent was to make people laugh,
but these guys,
their intent was to put their dick
inside of a child that's fucking.
And they judged him and they judged me
fucking crazy.
While hypocrisy knows no bounds and I
think,
you know,
anybody that's doing anything like that,
it's just a sickness that in
comprehensible these fucking guys,
man.
So they put you through some shit.
Like you went through this for a long
time.
Like my,
my lawyer when I first met my lawyer,
I told him,
he was like,
look,
they want you to settle.
And he goes,
I could,
um,
get it reduced,
get it reduced.
So like 20 grand.
And I was,
I told them,
I said,
if I do that,
I'm fucking everyone,
like any comic in Canada is going to be
fucked because I'm going to set this
weird precedent.
So I told him,
I was like,
I'd rather give you 100,000
then give them five.
So then he.
But he told me,
he was like,
we can't win the cause I didn't go to
court.
I went to the human rights tribunal.
I was judged by the human rights
tribunal and the Human Rights Commission
was bringing me there,
so it's me versus them judged by them.
So he told me you're definitely going to
lose to kangaroo court,
but he said,
he said,
uh,
then will appeal and the government will
probably accept the,
to,
to listen to the case again.
And then he goes,
then you'll win that.
And,
but so I said,
yes.
I was like,
look,
I have to do this.
And I'm out.
I,
I loved rocky and there was something
weird about.
I was like,
this is fucking rocky.
I'm going to be,
I'm going to lose the champ.
So,
so then like I was,
something really weird happened to me
though is I didn't,
I didn't think it did affect me this
much because when I was in court and I
saw this kid's family fucking crying and
I was like,
holy fuck,
okay.
These people really took this shit
seriously.
And I felt it.
It was weird because my,
my joke,
my intent was to make people laugh.
And this kid,
I've fucking nothing against this kid.
Like I don't,
I don't,
I don't not like them,
I don't know.
But then to see that they took this
seriously and then the,
how the media was portraying me,
like uh,
the in,
I did a series of shows in Edinburgh and
there's a newspaper,
Montreal,
the wrote a Mike Ward,
Mike Ward is getting rich off of this
little boy and I was doing shows in
Edinburgh that no one makes money.
They're like,
I was playing like a 200 seat theater.
And I was like,
oh,
these fuckers are making me look like
I'm becoming rich because of this little
kid.
You became a target.
And then quick bait.
That's how they get people to pay
attention.
And I didn't think it did affect me.
But the thing that I think the reason
why it did affect,
affect me is if all you get is hate,
you can block hate out.
It's super easy to block Keto and,
and if all you get is love,
that's easy too.
But I was getting hate and love so,
so I'd be like,
you know,
I wouldn't let the Hayden.
But then someone had shown me love so
I'd open up and then the hated come in
and it was just so fucking weird and I
was like googling myself too much.
I'd be like,
Oh fuck,
okay.
There's an article about me in,
in Russia,
and then I google translate to see that
I'm a piece of garbage.
It was weird and then I just saw I shows
weren't fun anymore.
So I was doing shows and it people were
like,
I'd get these weird hecklers.
And I was like,
I don't,
I,
I didn't like comedy anymore and this is
the only thing I've ever done my whole
life.
This is the only thing I've ever loved.
Like I don't have kids because of
comedy,
because I was like,
I know I'm not the type of person.
Like,
like you're good at organizing your
life.
If I had kids,
I like the way I live my life,
I'd be a horrible father.
So I never had kids because of that.
And then I was like,
fuck,
the only thing I liked I don't like
anymore.
And now I don't have kids,
which is weird.
But that,
yeah,
so I went through this to get out of the
funk,
uh,
took about a year and a half.
Wow.
And I told like,
um,
I didn't have,
like I make a good living but I'm a
Canadian comics so I make Canadian comic
money like,
so.
So I had money,
I had money to pay,
like it's cost me 150 so far in lawyer
fees.
I,
so far it's ongoing.
It's ongoing because now the appeal is,
the appeal is going to be cheap though.
It's going to be like only a couple
thousand but,
and I have that.
I had um,
I had to Bruce Hills from just for
laughs that organize the benefit for me.
Bruce is the best fucking person on the
world.
He,
he raised about 20.
I had a,
a,
a go fund me the raise 30.
So I paid 100 grand and then I had 50,
I had people helping me and that pretty
much got rid of all my savings.
So I told my manager I didn't like doing
shows anymore.
So it was like book me the minimum
amount of shows that I can,
you know,
I can pay my bills because my,
like,
I've,
you know,
my wife doesn't work.
So I was,
he booked me like a week of shows and so
three weeks out of the month I was going
through this weird depression one week
of the month I was doing shows,
pretending like everything was okay.
And that took like maybe a year,
a year and a half of me going through
this really,
really weird,
weird funk.
But the thing that was good,
I um,
I don't meditate but I spend my days in
the bath,
like I just be like lying down in the
bath,
just staring at the ceiling,
drinking wine.
Like I was drinking wine in my bathtub
all day,
like at least four hours a day.
Wow.
And then,
um,
and I could feel like,
like what,
you never know when you're in a weird
funk where the bottom's going to be.
But once you start going back up then
you know,
okay,
I'm getting out of this.
And then when I started feeling better,
like I was like,
okay,
I'm feeling better,
a little better,
a little better.
And then I'm like six.
I've been out of it like six months ago.
I called my manager six months ago and I
was like,
okay,
I'm back a book,
this,
I gotta get,
I gotta get some money again.
Well here's the news cycle.
And Canada gone away from it.
Yeah,
definitely helps too.
yeah,
definitely.
Like people will find new things.
Yeah.
This is a thing like people,
whenever people go after you,
you,
it affects you.
And you remember.
And then two weeks later people don't
even remember.
Even people that I had this woman that
she had written me on my facebook,
like this 60 year old woman that her
facebook profile is her with a cat and
you know,
again,
no clouds and a sweet old lady.
And she'd written a,
I'm happy your mom died because if she
was still alive,
she,
uh,
she'd kill herself.
Seeing what her son has become.
And I was like,
Oh,
you fuck a bitch?
But I started like,
I,
I see.
I go to her page,
uh,
I kept on going or a page now and uh,
like I'm a better month ago I did an
interview and she shared it and she was
like,
oh,
like I was a good person again.
I was like this frizzy,
crazy bitch.
Yeah.
Has probably a medication.
Do you remember saying that to you?
And what's even crazier is I keep going
back to her page.
That's crazy.
You're crazy.
It's fucked up.
Yeah.
She's on the fucking Roseanne type.
Adderall.
She's probably whacked out of her hand
or something,
you know,
who knows what she's on.
And alcohol really helped.
Like,
I know it's not good,
but alcohol really helped.
And um,
so you recommend it,
recommend it if you're.
Because it's a depressant,
but it,
it's a number.
It's better to be sad and drunk than
just said.
Interesting.
Yeah.
And,
but I knew like,
and now I still drank,
but I drank my way less,
way less.
I was drinking,
I was drinking maybe like four,
four or five,
maybe six,
26 ounces a week.
Like I was drinking almost a full bottle
of vodka every day.
That would be impressive.
But yesterday jake,
the snake was on 80 mile drive with
Andre the giant,
I think 48 beers.
Yeah.
No,
that's fucking crazy.
And he didn't already eight peers.
So yeah.
No,
no,
I was not a wine though,
man.
Yeah.
And the fact that you just sit in the
tub and just in your diabetic.
Right?
I'm diabetic.
You're not supposed to be drinking wine,
are you?
Oh,
there aren't that many carbs in wine,
like not that much sugar.
Not that much.
But you're drinking it all day.
She'll catch up now,
but that's why I switched to vodka.
Good mood.
Don't stop thinking about my health.
Getting organic.
Just make sure it's organic.
You'll be fun.
Exactly.
Yeah.
So,
um,
do they give you a time where you have
to finish this thing or where it's going
to be settled by?
I just got.
This was many years ago,
right?
What year did it start this?
This is a joke.
I wrote in 2009 and I did in a special.
That was from 2010.
I did a tour 2000,
10 to 2012,
so this is a super old joke and what's
fucked up defending something that you
wrote 10 years ago,
like people were like,
what were you thinking when you wrote
that joke?
And I'm like,
I don't know what the fuck.
I was thinking not even year.
And some one guy told me,
he was like,
you know,
you can't say things like that anymore
nowadays.
And I was like,
oh,
I know.
I wrote that joke 10 years ago.
Ten years ago.
We used to do say shit.
That was way fucking meter than that.
Yeah,
there's some funny dark jokes,
you know,
I always bring up is Brian Holzman bit
that he did right after.
I remember that Susan Smith Lady that
drowned her kids.
Do you remember?
Yeah.
Crazy shit.
They found this lady drove her car into
the river and just drowned her kids did
it on purpose and a right after it
happened.
Brian holds,
but it goes onstage.
The comedy story goes.
Ladies and gentlemen,
I heard those are bad kids.
They sat that close to the TV.
They never put away their blocks,
the constantly spilling the milk.
Those kids will not be missed and
everybody was like,
Oh shit.
It was so ridiculously mean and funny at
the same time,
and people have to understand that
that's you're in a nightclub.
People are drinking,
you are allowed freedom of expression.
It is fun.
These aren't bad people.
Holtz was not a bad person.
You're not a bad person,
bad people.
These are people that are doing a
certain type of art form and here's
what's weird,
this type of art form,
when you do you say mean shit that you
don't really mean for whatever reason
you can't do that because you're a guy
on stage and it's too much like you're
actually saying it,
but if you were saying it in a movie,
if you're planning a fine,
be fine.
You're playing a mean fucking villain
characters saying awful shit in a movie.
Everybody would be like,
yeah,
Sam Jackson is a great guy.
He didn't really kill that guy over the
cheeseburger like that.
That was just a.
his character did that.
He's a murderous monster,
right?
He's screaming Bible Vengeance,
Bible verses and then fucking shooting
this dude,
but nobody has a problem with that
because it's Samuel Jackson's obviously
an actor in pulp fiction was a movie.
We don't have any confusion.
Santa file.
Yeah.
And then movie.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
There's something that's fucked up about
Canada though.
There's a makeup artist named him.
He quits.
He's a Sudep five times.
That's like the GSP of makeup artist.
But he,
yeah,
he's special effects makeup and he did
this movie,
sort of like a,
just a,
like a demo of what he can do.
It was a short film where he had this
little kid and he murdered the kid.
He didn't actually murder the kid and
uh,
and then he put that out on the Internet
with,
you know,
his name at the end and the whole who
played who and some fucking Weirdo in
Germany saw this and thought it was real
cold.
Interpol,
Interpol called the Montreal cops.
Montreal police went to remain
[inaudible] house to arrest him for
murder.
And then he said no,
but the kid,
they were like,
we saw the video.
And he goes,
yeah,
but the kid see the kid in the video,
he's my neighbor.
So they went to meet the,
the murder victim,
which was a little kid neighbor and they
saw he was alive and they still,
they took,
they took them to court because they
said what he did incited violence and,
and he and everyone told them they were
like,
you're gonna win for sure because this
is just stupid.
But the thing is he had to defend
himself.
He had to go to court and he had to.
And when you win a court case like that,
like if it costs you 30,
50,
80,000
to defend yourself,
the government doesn't give you your
money back.
And that's a stupid like my case,
I find it,
it's Kinda stupid.
But his case is fucking retarded because
no one ever kills someone.
Films it.
And then has the end credits.
Yeah,
no.
Well,
if they did,
now they'll do it.
Because you said no one ever does that.
I would like to point you to a podcast
with Mike Ward.
We clearly showed some fucking psycho
set established.
He's like,
challenge accepted.
This is why Jordan Peterson was so
adamant that that bill was dangerous and
that it would be bad for everybody in
bad for free speech.
When we look at it in America,
I think we have a distorted perception
because I don't think we totally
understand your system of government
when it comes to censorship because you
guys don't have freedom of expression
the way we do in America.
What's fucked up too about being
Canadian is since all of our TV and all
of our movies are American,
like the first thing I asked my lawyer,
I was like,
what about?
What about the First Amendment?
He was like,
yeah,
we don't.
We don't have it.
I was like,
no,
I know we don't.
I know we're not America,
but we must have the Canadian version of
that,
and he was like,
no,
there's no like,
like people all over the world that talk
shit about the states.
The states is the only place in the
world that speech is protected by law.
You can still get in trouble by saying
shit.
You can still get it.
Protests.
Did you see Michelle Wolf Donk on the
president today?
No.
She dunked on trump.
Dude.
Donald trump talk shit about her saying
that she bombed so hard last year at the
White House press correspondents'
dinner,
which unfortunately for him we've all
seen the video and she didn't bother at
all.
In fact she killed.
She had some funny shit and so he wrote
today that she bumped so hard.
They're now going to bring someone like
they're not going to do comedy anymore.
They're going to bring in an author.
Here it is.
Yeah.
So called comedian Michelle was bombed
so badly as you're in the White House
correspondence dinner that this year for
the first time in decades they will have
an author instead of a comedian.
Good first step to come back with dying
evening and tradition.
Exclamation point.
Maybe.
I will go question.
She writes.
I bet you'd be on my side if I had
killed a journalist.
Hashtag best.
That's good.
We'll get.
She's got 297,769
likes.
Sixty 4,000.
One hundred 69 retweets.
One of which is mine.
That was brutal.
That shit is hilarious.
She's,
she's a savage and he's.
That's silly.
What he did was silly.
You can't say someone bought,
but he does.
I mean that's his move,
right?
It doesn't have to be real,
but you shouldn't say someone bombed
when we can watch the fact that it
didn't bomb.
You pull it up at anytime you want and
you could watch that video.
She killed him.
Say that though,
because since the people that have seen
it,
no,
she didn't bump,
but the people that didn't see it,
now they think,
I don't think it matters.
I think in the mag a mindset.
Okay.
If you had a mag,
a mindset,
it would be you don't need any reality
other than the reality that you all
decided upon and you press forward with
fucking hashtags and American flags and
red and white hats and you just keep
moving.
You just keep moving and eventually what
you're doing is you're like hacking the
news cycle because the news cycle is
just so everything lasts a day.
Maybe two days,
four days sick.
No,
he's a fuck about stormy daniels.
Stop talking about it.
It's over,
like that's what's going on.
I mean that's.
And they've kind of figured that out and
sort of an odd way like even him with
the stormy Daniels.
Thank you.
Still talk about it.
It'll go away.
It's going away.
Not only that,
like the fucking lawyer now he got
charged with domestic violence.
The lawyer for stone stormy day.
The guy who was going to run for
president now he got charged with
domestic violence and check out a
restraining order.
It's over baby.
So like you just keep moving.
All they do is just keep moving,
just keep moving and eventually go like
this,
like yeah,
obviously she didn't bomb.
He can say she did and even she'd done
because them keep moving,
just keep moving.
It doesn't do nothing ever sticks
because he's caught a wave.
Like there's the new cycles.
So crazy.
Everything's so crazy.
There's nothing stationary that we call
can examine for long periods of time.
Everything's just moving.
Everything's just constantly moving.
There's no stability.
It's k with him in the White House.
He knows there's no stability because he
actually got to be the president.
Yeah,
he figured like he treats everyone like
a comic treats hecklers.
Yes.
And he's said,
and people that say that he still,
he's,
he's so smart,
like he figured he figured all this shit
figured out that all the protocol that
was established in the fucking 18
hundreds,
early $19.
It doesn't mean anything anymore.
You know,
this is not Harry Truman.
This is,
this is not George Washington.
This is 2018.
There's porn everywhere.
Okay.
Oxycontin's are killing people and no
one's talking about it.
Cigarettes are killing people.
No politician ever brings up the fact
half a million people die every year in
this country.
Just from cigarettes.
Shut the fuck up,
keep moving.
And then,
you know,
he said he had that little jeff
sessions,
little munchkin working for him forever
with saying that good people don't smoke
marijuana like the whole thing.
Chaos.
He's knows it's chaos because he's the
top guy.
You imagine being the top guy in
something as insane as like the United
States governmental system and seeing
the lobbyists and special interest
groups and all the money and all the
fucking cast and Saudi Arabia's cutting
up journalists and you gotta keep your
mouth shut.
It's fucking madness.
And he's the top madman.
No wonder why he tweets shit like this.
He knows there's no rules so crazy.
It could all fall apart at any minute.
It's so fucking wacky.
I was watching today.
Him pardoning a Turkey.
I don't know why you guys still do this
kind of crazy shit.
But he was probably tweeting about Jim
Acosta being a fag and then turns around
and goes,
this Turkey,
good Turkey.
He came here illegally.
Let them.
It's so stupid.
What did he do with that Turkey?
He,
um,
he just,
he just decided to.
Turkey gets to live.
Yeah.
What happens to those immediately when
they shut the cameras off for sure.
I'm not telling you you're going to eat
you for Christmas.
So the whole idea that that would be a
thing.
It's so fucking stupid.
We're going to decide one Turkey,
one turkeys are good Turkey.
Yeah,
and everyone's like,
save it.
Save it.
Nope.
Out with the ax.
Psych.
I was just kidding.
Put his head on a log chunk.
People would freak out.
But you knew I was going to kill a
Turkey.
Why were you upset that I'm killing this
Turkey?
Yeah,
but it's all in St Louis.
Yesterday he tweeted,
he said some,
uh,
I believe Saudi Arabia may have been
behind that Kosha.
Shaggy.
Murdered.
Like,
did you just figure that out?
What is he a detective?
It took this long.
Everybody knew.
Well,
okay,
let's examine that.
You stay.
Everybody knew,
right?
Yeah.
How much do you really know?
Only what?
Turkey to told us.
Only what the.
Everybody tells you.
I'm not,
I'm not saying I'm not advocating
conspiracy theories,
but anyone who says they know what
happened.
Like Jesus,
the only people that know what happened
or the people that did it,
and then the people who think they know
what happened to the people that are
examining it and then the people that
are reading third,
fourth,
fifth,
sixth hand about what happened.
We're just talking shit,
you know.
Oh,
they killed him.
Are you sure?
Okay.
I'm sure this is what I'm sure.
I'm sure that if you stare at the sun,
it burns your eyes.
Right.
I tried it.
I've,
a lot of people have done it.
I'm sure you know.
I'm sure that if you a light dead trees
up on fire,
they,
it becomes a wildfire.
It's very dangerous.
I'm sure of that.
That's real.
Who killed that guy?
I'm,
I'm sure someone killed them.
They're all admitting they killed them.
Pretty sure that pretty sure.
Pretty sure.
I don't really know.
Right?
Because one day saying that they had,
the Turkish government had recordings,
but they didn't want to share them
publicly because they didn't want the
other embassies knowing how they record
embassies because you're not supposed
to.
Exactly.
So that's what they said.
If you're not supposed to,
but I think they probably all do it.
Yeah.
Yeah,
definitely.
Well,
apparently there's video and audio is
what I read,
but I don't know if that's true.
Fuck.
Do I know when you want to say,
oh,
they killed them.
They fucking killed him.
Said that he,
there is an audio tape,
but he wasn't going to hear it because
he didn't want to hear it.
It was totally.
Didn't need to.
Yeah.
You know what,
man,
that brings me back to that movie.
Grizzly
man,
remember grizzly man,
they had audio.
The guy got eaten by a grizzly bear,
lived with Chrissy bills forever.
Everybody's like is going to get eaten
and then one day gets heat and along the
way,
have you ever seen the documentary?
It's a Warner Herzog movie.
It's one of the greatest unintentional
comedy of all time.
It's really good what?
Get Lit and watch it.
You're going to fucking love it.
It's a guy who is.
There's something wrong with him and
right away like you,
you start making judgments.
Like,
is he gang?
I think he's gay.
I think he's gay and he fighting it and
one of the ways he fights it,
he goes and lives in the forest.
I'm not bullshitting.
He didn't get the term bears.
No,
he's saving bears,
but he's like so feminine and he brings
his fucking camera and he's walking
through the forest.
He goes,
I wish I was just gay,
but I'm not gay.
If I was gay then I would just go meet a
guy at a truck stop or something,
but I'm not gay.
So it's like who?
Who are walking around by themselves in
the woods surrounded by bears going,
wow,
files just gay or be so easy,
like,
do you hear how you're saying it?
Like the stereotypical gay voices.
One of the weirdest things because
there's like not a single masculine
heterosexual male who uses that speech
pattern.
Like that speech pattern.
It's exclusive to gay men.
Like I'm not gay,
whatever.
Here we go.
I was like,
this is a speech pattern that we
associate with homosexuals and you know,
you could say someone's prejudice,
but you look,
you know it's true.
That's true.
You know,
you hear someone talking and saying
homosexual type things in that voice you
have.
It sounds like a gay guy.
Have you ever had.
I had a friend come out of the closet to
me and the whole time he was coming out
I was like,
Oh shit,
I'm going to have to pretend like I'm
surprised because he was like,
look,
I got a Ta.
And I was like,
Oh fuck.
It's weird.
It is weird.
Yeah.
Well,
you know what it's weird is any
discussion of it is deemed homophobic.
It's not homophobic at all.
No problem with me being gay,
but it is weird that some percentage,
whether it's 10 percent,
20 percent,
whatever the number is of gay guys talk
gay.
They're adorable.
You know,
they say gay things.
They have their fingers.
Justin Martin deals.
Good friend of mine.
Gaze.
Fuck loves it.
Swings.
He swings when he walks he sachets as he
walks into a room.
He's hilarious too.
Fucking funny.
Standup comic.
But he's,
he,
you know,
he will take on those kind of vocal
affectations,
you know,
not negative.
There's a comic of Montreal.
He's a good friend named John Sanka
Dart.
He's a gay guy,
but a gay audiences don't like him
because he's a guy guy.
Like he's from a small town in Manitoba
or whatever.
So gay people don't like him cause he,
cause he's,
he's a guy guy and then we were talking
last summer and I was like,
you should do a show and
call it no gays allowed because whenever
he has gay people it always goes wrong
because they get angry and that's so
weird.
He's a guy guy but he's gay and they get
mad.
But here's what's funny,
if he was a guy guy but he was straight,
they'd probably want to turn him.
Yeah,
he should pretend to be a straight guy
that's like really easy to turn.
A buddy of mine who was a makeup artist,
super good dude who's gay as fuck.
And he was always telling me about
these.
He would do airtech street guys that
would suck his dick straight of him
suck.
They're laughing.
I was like,
ah.
He,
he would give me details like what is
going on?
What's going on?
They like it.
They get a thrill out of turning guys,
but I don't think they're turning
anybody.
I had a friend that used to,
when I first moved to Montreal,
we he'd be like,
let's go to a gay bar because a lot of
women go there because they don't want
to get hit on,
and then he was like,
we'll just pretend like we're gay and
we'll try to have sex with the lady for
the first time.
He was really good at it because he was
like super thin,
so he did look like a gay guy,
but I just looked like a fucking weird,
weird fucking Chubby,
straight guy going into a gay bar.
Like fuck gay guys built like you.
But I'm always surprised whenever I see
chubby gay guys.
I don't believe.
I don't believe they're really gay
because I'm like,
okay,
I'm a dude.
I wouldn't fuck someone shaped like
that.
Hm.
Interesting.
Yeah.
Maybe A.
Maybe they just have different genes.
I see it differently.
I don't know.
Something about them as attracted to
someone who has got a lot of natural
resources stored in the skin.
You know what?
If it gets really cold out,
stay alive.
He could keep me warm.
He'll protect me.
Keep fucking me.
Hang onto him.
Oh,
did you?
I don't know if you're doing an archery
today,
but did you see that tribe this morning?
I saw a video we're talking about right
before the podcast,
but the guy in India who's trying to
convert them apparently January San and
they shot him full of arrows with the
one of the last uncontacted tribes in
the world.
But what a doofus.
What'd you think was gonna Happen?
Right?
Jamie said the guy's been there before.
Did you say that?
So they knew him.
The other guy.
Well,
I don't know.
The people that killed them knew them
when they say there's between 50 and 100
people on this island,
I believe.
See if we can get a good article on it.
Set the number of trying to pull up on
our book.
So those are like 50 or 50 to 150
people.
They don't exactly know.
Um,
and they,
they came there just say from it's the
size of Manhattan.
So the island and they came here from
Africa,
like what is it?
Sixty thousand years ago I'd read them.
I don't remember exactly where I.
The article earlier.
India?
Yeah.
Someone in India or near near near
India.
So island fucking dude was trying to
bring them to Jesus and they said if you
liked the guy will introduce it to them.
They filled up motherfucker full.
Oh Wow.
It's in the middle of nowhere.
All that.
Fuck.
That bitch is in the middle of nowhere.
So they came off of Africa.
That's crazy.
How the fuck you see all that shit.
Yeah.
You know what's interesting too,
in England they call uh,
people from India,
Asians,
they think of that as Asia because it
is.
But we got weird with oriental at some
point in time.
Oriental became derogatory,
some weird way.
Oriana was normal like oriental rugs.
That was like a thing you'd go to
oriental rugs.
Yeah.
That's like if someone was saying,
you know,
toothpaste,
like,
hey,
hey motherfucker,
you can't say that shit anymore.
But at one point in time oriental was
like a total.
This is a real thing.
Yeah.
It was part of the language.
Um,
but so now we say Asian because we try
to be politically correct,
but Asia is fucking giant.
There's a lot of different kinds of
folks in Asia.
You know,
what,
what those,
like the people that ended up on that
island one dude,
they,
how the fuck do you,
you're running away from something to
end up.
Well everybody's,
that's,
you know,
if you read about the migration of
people from Africa spreading out,
that's a big part of what they're doing
is trying to get away from people that
are trying to tell them,
yeah,
it's all either they run out of
resources,
they're run a food or they're being,
they're being forced out of areas like
new people come in,
people escape and survive and did our
entire history as human beings.
It's like bigger,
more powerful human beings move into an
area and kill and rape and then spread,
spread out and then keep going and
everybody else just keeps going and they
eventually fortify in the distance.
You get a new city and they try to hold
them off and then new people coming
through.
I mean there's so many instances from
the mon goals to the Romans being go
back and back and matt all through
history,
but if you broke it down,
if you looked at it like a math problem,
like what's happening here,
here's this happening.
These groups of people get together and
then they develop some shit there,
kills other groups of people and they
push into those groups of people and try
to fuck their chicks,
steal money,
fuck the chicks,
eat their food,
and then they do the same thing and then
and then people go back and forth and
this is all people have done.
Like there's never been a time where no
one was at war.
Like if you've ever gone through human
history,
there's no like,
well there was a period of a hundred
years where there was no warrants.
It's never happened.
Never ever happened.
You're the best guy to ask about.
This isn't impressive how they built
those arrows,
right?
The craftsmanship because their proper
error,
what they look like.
They have pictures of the arrows,
but apparently he died.
Just have the arrows hitting them.
So the way I was thinking it was in
order for an Arrow to be done properly,
right,
and you could aim and then hit someone
and killed them.
It has to go through the whole structure
of the pelvis.
No,
it doesn't have to.
I mean,
especially with the kid hit a bunch of
times,
you know,
if they hit him a bunch of times,
they get a shot him in the gut.
Shitty arrows.
Well I don't think they have shitty
hours because they need them to survive.
Right.
So there has got to be island animals
and they're hunting these animals.
But it's not that hard for these people
and these kinds of tribes to,
if they have the proper would on the
island,
you know,
they um,
they've been.
People have been making bows and arrows
for a long time and they,
they'll use certain fibers from certain
trees and they weave them together and
make a bowstring and you know,
if they have enough goodwood and they
have good fiber and they have the
knowledge.
I mean,
even if they don't have metal,
you could still to this day I found one
in Nevada.
I found an old,
I don't know what era it's from,
but I found a an arrowhead,
but while I was actually bow hunting,
I found an actual arrowhead from some
native American tribe that they left by
and apparently they were like really
common,
like people find them all the time
because you think of the thousands of
years that the indigenous people were
here and all the different animals they
shot with bows and arrows.
They figured out how to do it so these
people must know how to do it too and if
they have enough good stone to make
something flint or something similar to
make the arrowheads or maybe they're
using something toxic,
maybe they have some sort of toxic plant
and they just dipping the tip of a
sharpened tip into it.
If if you dip the tip and something
toxic,
don't can you eat.
That means you can apparently,
but not the area near the question.
It's a good question.
I don't know,
but a lot of these tribes that shoot
things that shoot things with poison on
the end of their arrows.
Yeah.
Well,
the idea is that they just didn't want
to eat it,
right?
They don't,
if they don't hit it perfectly,
they're not going to wait for the
perfect shot.
They're just trying to hit it so they
can hit it in the ass or in the neck or
wherever the fuck they hid it.
If they have poison,
that thing's going to die.
You know,
they used poison for a lot of weird shit
to the,
uh,
use poison to fish.
It's really strange.
They tape this season.
The fish.
Yeah.
It's crazy.
They take this plant and they smash it
up
and they make this green.
That was,
that the Yanomami may have,
um,
some more,
maybe Bolivia or something like that.
It's one of those tribal peoples that
lives almost,
almost uncontacted,
but still some like w they'll have like
under armour tee shirts on and it's
weird.
It's weird,
but you know,
the barefoot and they take these plants
and I forget what the planet is,
but they smash this plant up and make
like this green pulp.
And then they put this pulp in these
ponds and these fish just float.
It's some sort of toxin and it just
fucks these fish up and they just float
up to the top and then they'd go and
scoop the fish and take them out of
there,
but it like paralyzes them.
It's not toxic to us,
I guess.
I don't know man.
I mean maybe they lit up,
but I guess you have to be really
fucking hungry to think,
okay,
I'm not killing enough or getting enough
fruits or vegetables.
I'm going to poison these things and I'd
rather die being poisoned than starving
to death.
Well,
I think
full have been on the edge of survival,
like they've figured out survival down
to like everything in their area.
They know what's edible.
They know what's dangerous,
what to avoid,
what to cultivate,
what to seek
out.
They just,
you know,
they know how to do it,
so if these people are on,
if it's a resource rich island and it
seems to be like an island in the middle
of the ocean,
as long as they don't kill too much,
as long as they keep a certain healthy
population of animals around are
cognizant of that as this.
These people,
yes,
the video I found in 2008 where some
fishermen or someone found them and them
coconuts.
Wow.
So these people apparently,
um,
if you,
if you follow the story,
they came from Africa 60 something
thousand years ago and I guess probably
during the ice age the coastline was
very different,
right?
The water levels were way lower and then
when the ice melted,
the oceans rose and then we get,
we got now.
So maybe it was a much larger island or
maybe it was like the bearing landmass
where you could get across it.
Fuck your friends.
Speak a language that no one else not
even close to anything else since it's
been so long.
Fuck man.
Here's combined with Lang throw it here
is combined with body language who
seemed to have a link.
So they were like telling him to throw
things and they'd given him coconuts.
That's pretty cool.
It's crazy how friendly they are without
knowing who the person is and where
they're from.
Well,
I mean the dude's giving them free food,
so I think they're pumped.
You get a bunch of free.
Coconut is definitely a way to come
friends with people,
that guy,
if that guy had coconuts instead of a
Bible,
probably through bibles,
they're like,
fuck it.
Tried to eat the Bible up there.
Like,
motherfucker,
look at that.
Imagine some guy just showing up and
giving you free food.
Can you see my Dick?
Is that what is,
what is this video?
Some videos.
Outrageous.
That's a real translation.
Yeah.
I,
I really.
Um,
so it says a wooden act similar to a
mountain acts.
Yeah.
That's a fucking crazy looking carried
by all men.
So they.
Yeah.
So they might not even have like metal.
It seems like if he's got a wooden acts,
I wonder if they have what they're using
for arrowheads and stuff like that.
This kind of fucking interests.
Oh dude is fascinating man.
The thing is,
it's really what's weird about it is you
can't really go there like Jay,
you guys ever read or watched that movie
about the city ofZ ,
the lost city of z?
Is that what it was called?
It was about an explorer from England
who made his way to South America and
eventually got eaten by cannibals.
Allegedly,
they think,
oh,
but he was looking for this last Mayan
or Aztec city.
Was it a Mayan city?
Lost City of Z.
Amazon.
Yeah,
so he was looking for some,
you know,
apparently,
and they've.
They know this for sure now.
There's some really,
really,
really ancient cities in the Amazon and
they don't know what they are.
They don't know from when.
They don't know who built them,
so they don't even know who it's
different culture.
Well,
it's a culture that's long gone and it's
the area where they had the city has
been absorbed by the jungle,
so they,
they find it,
I think either from satellites or from
some kind of imagery where they're
noticing these really obvious grid
patterns that indicate irrigation and
that they had fields and they had
streets and so this.
There's this English explorer.
What was the gentleman's name?
Harry Faucet.
Here's the book's not bad.
Percy Percy Fawcett and so this,
this dude went to the jungles of Brazil
multiple times looking for this lost
city of gold to 18,
60.
So yeah.
So he was really,
it's a cool movie,
but not,
it's not the best movie,
but it's cool because it's like you get
to see the lost city of z.
He found it before he was killed.
No,
no,
no.
Like he found something.
He found that I don't want to spoil the
movie,
but it's um,
it's not a bad movie.
What's interesting to me is that these
people,
you just got to put yourself in the mind
of people that lived in 1860 and they
literally had no idea what the fuck was
going on in South America.
They just.
But someone would come back and say,
author has a story of his jetties down
the jungle river and the guy would stand
up.
We met the uncontacted tribe and they
would talk about,
I have brought back pod pottery and this
is a spearhead and you know,
and here's drawings of the animals that
I saw as get drawings of crocodiles and
fucking giant Paranas and shit.
It must,
must've been guys that made that shit up
though,
like the difference between a guy that
actually had real pottery and just me
getting my wife,
hey,
make a full will.
You know,
that happened with the dinosaurs,
right?
That people would pretend to say I have
seen dinosaurs like in Australia.
No,
no,
no.
When,
when they first discovered that a
dinosaur was a thing,
some people started faking it and they
would come up with fake dinosaurs to a
disorder,
like boost their science credit and
these are like legitimate people or
thought to be,
you know,
the credibility accountability rather
back then was not what it is today.
Like you don't.
I don't think the peer review process
was the sound of these fucking people
were maniacs out there just trying to
pretend that they found dinosaurs.
So they use like go fuck a buffalo park
or some shit.
And they're like,
look what I found.
I can't believe it's right here.
I mean I was just digging randomly.
Even now though,
even if you found bones from an elephant
and you said,
Hey,
I dug this out in Vermont.
People like people would be like that
camp.
Well,
what is that thing that's like nine feet
long for a little while and then you
know,
actual scientists will get ahold of it.
I go,
well,
this is an elephant bone.
You fucking idiot.
This is a dinosaur.
But if we were in 17,
46.
Yeah.
What year was it when they did that with
the dinosaur thing?
Yeah,
there were some sort of like a battle,
like everybody's trying to discover the
latest and the greatest.
They'd pee shit together.
It didn't belong.
It was.
There was some weird wackiness.
But you know what's fascinating to me is
that something has to
die in like mud or it has to die and it
has to be at the bottom of the ocean or
a lake in silk.
Something has to happen to preserve
those bones because if it doesn't then
you get nothing.
That's why we don't,
we don't know Jack Shit about what like
octopus look like with Octopi looked
like $5 million years ago,
60 million years ago.
Like,
like the cracking,
like that could have easily been a real
thing.
Right.
A fucking super enormous octopus that
could eat whales because there are some
big fucking words.
I've seen some videos.
Yeah,
but they don't have.
There's no bones.
No.
They just die in mud.
Yeah.
It has to tie in something to become
fossilized now.
Yeah.
It's weird.
It is.
When you're seeing that fossil,
do you know that that's not really the
bone that has all the mineral that has
replaced the bone over like thousands
and millions of years or whatever it
takes?
Yeah.
When something's fossilized,
like if you see like a fossilized shark
tooth and it's black,
that's not the real color of the teeth.
It's the color of all the minerals that
have replaced what the tooth used to be
as it remains compressed and all this
sludge and mud and shit over millions of
years.
It's pretty freaky shit.
So like when you see these dinosaur
bones,
they're like,
they're fossilized.
A lot of them,
like a lot of the bones that we find a
dead things they've become like a piece
of rock to could look completely
different because I've heard people say
that most dinosaurs that we look at now
that we think about how they look,
they really had feathers now thing.
I just assumed that the sound of
Jurassic Park is correct.
Probably isn't.
Whatever the fuck they sounded like.
They might not have made any noise here.
The great dinosaur fossil hooks.
Oh,
the new one.
China has enjoyed unprecedented gold
rush of feather dinosaur fossils,
but how many are real?
Yeah,
there have been some feathered fossils.
If you go to the.
There's a museum in Montana and Bozeman
in the museum,
some sort of science museum,
and they have a one of those rappers,
a velociraptor with feathers,
like a model of it,
like a life size Velossa,
like like a freaky demon.
That my first thing you ever want to see
before you die.
I'm afraid of birds,
so imagine how fucking big bird like
that.
I lose my fucking mind.
Here it is.
Here's the bone wars.
The great dinosaur rush.
A period of intense and ruthlessly
competitive fossil hunting and discovery
during the gilded age of American
history,
marked by the heated rivalry between
Edwin drinker cope drinker.
That's what Middle Lane Bro of the
Academy of Natural Sciences of
Philadelphia.
And whilst this guy's name authentic
real othniel,
what do you say that is off Neil Othniel
Charles Marsh of the peabody museum of
natural history of the year.
Each of the two paleontologists use
underhanded methods to outdo each other
in the field,
resulting resorted to bribery,
theft,
and the destruction of bones.
East scientist also sought to ruin his
rivals reputation and cut off its
funding.
Use the attacks in scientific
publications.
So this doesn't seem like these are the
people that were using fake stuff.
I was like a fake shit.
Yeah,
this.
If this was happening,
they probably fake shit.
People are all crazy man.
Those guys like doing that.
You can tell like at first that were
real scientists and then they became
famous and they're like,
oh shit.
I like being famous.
Imagine if I enjoy being a famous
scientist in scholar.
Both the Chinese one.
What are you getting now from and also
the Chinese is not known for making
counterfeit stuff,
so I don't believe that article.
Right.
That's what they do.
They make whole cities.
They made Paris.
If you go to China,
there's a Paris.
I was in China,
I get a tour of China like two years ago
and there's one of the guys bugging me.
He told me his,
his girlfriend loved France and there's
a neighborhood in Shanghai.
It's exactly like France.
So he brought her to France and then she
was like,
not the Chinese ones better because it's
the exact replica and they do that now
in the Arab.
My knees one is better.
She says Emirates,
they redid the.
They,
they redid a,
I think the,
the Sorbonne and the like.
They redid buildings from France.
So you're in the Arab Emirates and your.
Everything is exactly the same as it is
in France except it's all like Saudis
and people from Kuwait was a weird thing
to do.
Try to recreate a historical building
that still exists.
Yeah.
Put that effort into creating something.
You have no white people copy.
I think it's because they like it,
it's probably complicated to to cause
they're like,
oh fuck,
we're gonna go to go to whatever country
is going to be food.
It's a food.
Going to be Halau.
Is it going to be complicated to go the
mosque?
Fuck it.
Let's just next to the mosque and we'll
be good.
This is enough oil money floating
around.
They could probably build a whole world
out in the desert.
They could visit New York City.
Here we are,
New York to fake Manhattan,
Brooklyn Bridge cab drivers or river
fucking makeover.
They're such dicks like that.
Building the biggest building in the
world in Dubai.
When you go in,
in the elevator,
they turned the lights off and it
becomes kind of like a ride and then it
starts going up and then it shows,
okay,
we're at the level that the biggest
building in New York City,
like the empire state building is here
at like whatever,
300 meters and then this is the biggest
building in Shanghai and then they.
So they want to just show,
look,
we got in the elevator,
the elevator,
like they're like,
no bitch.
Yeah.
I said,
well,
money since they did,
like the first time I was in Dubai,
the biggest building was a,
I don't know how big,
but they built one in Dubai and then the
year after Shanghai beat it by like
three meters.
And then Dubai was like,
fuck you,
we're going to beat you by 500 meters.
So it's like a,
it's a kilometer or almost like a,
like more than half a mile high.
It's crazy high.
More than half a mile high.
Yeah.
That's St and the city,
would you say it that way?
You look and the city in the 19
seventies didn't really exist.
So it was like,
this is fucking insane.
Like the national anthem could be the
eye of the tiger.
It's fucking insane how big it got so
quickly.
But they're all so fucking wretched.
It's insane.
Jamie,
what were you going to say?
Uh,
as you were saying that,
like,
I don't know why I'd definitely be
registered before,
but king's island,
which is a theme park in Ohio and
Cincinnati area,
there's the Eiffel Tower there.
There's also one somewhere else at
another park.
Oh really?
I didn't say exact replica.
One third replica.
Eiffel Tower that's been there since
like the seven.
But all those rich Arab countries will
be like,
instead of one third seven times vague
made of diamonds.
You can see,
you can see this Eiffel Tower from the
moon.
Gucci,
everything.
Yeah.
It's weird.
People do that.
But you know,
when you had that kind of money,
man,
you make me a France.
What else am I going to do for their
friends?
I want the countryside,
the whole thing,
man,
I want you to know I want to turn away
because you're like,
make it like now your puck has gotten so
big in three years.
I want to hear Joe Rogan Belt Rome.
He's got a fake robe.
Oh,
that's why to five compound somewhere.
Don't dumped off.
Start selling a freeze dried food.
Preparing everybody know water
purification tablets.
Get ready solar panels.
Did you like dishes?
Did you.
Is Your House okay?
Yeah,
we got lucky.
We got lucky that someone said Google
this,
that Malibu last six,
600 houses.
What?
Yeah,
someone said that the other day,
but everyone's hysterical.
It's hard to know if they're right or
not.
How many houses got lost at Malibu?
Because I know a lot of people that have
lost houses.
I know at least eight people that have
And how was the evacuation [inaudible]?
Was it like area like you,
you can just grab like one.
One or two things.
Grab
my laptop.
1,500
structures.
totally destroyed Jesus Christ.
So the number probably keeps going up,
but those are.
A lot of them are homes,
you know,
out of those 1500,
I don't know how many of them are homes,
but a lot of them are.
A lot of people lost their homes.
It's a,
it's a crazy thing that happens.
The wind gets behind that fire and
everything's dry and it just goes
straight to the water and there's almost
nothing they could do.
They lost so
many houses on point dume,
which you would think,
how the fuck is a fire going to get to
that?
Like if you ever see what point dume is,
it's like this beautiful area of very
wealthy people live in this,
this cliff overlooking the ocean.
I mean spectacular and like you would
never think that a wildfire we get
there,
but it was raining fire man.
That's point dume out there.
So,
so many of those houses got cooked man
and there's videos that people made of
them leaving their horrific.
There's like fire raining from the sky
everywhere you look houses on fire and
this is a super exclusive,
really rich area and no one could
protect it.
There was nothing they could do.
The firefighters did their best.
They saved as many structures as they
can,
but it was fucking raging man.
It was a rocks throw from my house when
we left.
We left at 2:00
in the morning,
Thursday night.
The traffic,
because the traffic is always crazy.
So when you evacuate and the traffic's
like that must,
you must freak out.
Scary is what happened to the people in
paradise,
California,
they were evacuating and something like
60 plus people died in their cars.
The fire just overcame cars and there's
nowhere to go and they're stuck in
gridlock and the fires literally coming
at them ready for this 80 football
fields a minute.
That's how fast it was.
Traveling at some.
At one point.
See what happens over the summer.
There's a town right outside of Athens,
Greece.
Yet wildfires took over.
The town was wiped off in a couple of
minutes.
People died in their cars and homes.
You couldn't get out.
They were just traveling.
That's what happens in paradise.
I think a lot more than a thousand
people are missing paradise.
Yeah.
They don't even know and the problem is
they'll never know like whatever was
there is incinerated.
There's nothing left.
Like they won't be able to get DNA that
it's over.
I mean it's the craziest fire they've
ever experienced it.
I think it's the scariest,
most destructive California wildfire
ever,
and that one,
the one down here was nothing compared
to that one in northern California and
comparison to the size and scope.
I mean that thing is fucking insane.
There's fire,
there's a photo of this one.
Firefighter has sort of iconic photo.
He standing on a rock and behind him the
whole mountain is on fire and it's just
like holy shit.
And people in my friend Brendan Child
was doing a show in Sacramento,
in Sacramento,
out his hotel room.
The whole street was filled with smoke.
You couldn't see shit.
He's like,
dude,
smoke is everywhere.
And he sent me a photo of the television
that was showing the air quality was
very poor.
Air Quality everywhere,
all through that area.
It's just all in red.
So it was all like people were walking
around with masks on and it would
literally be like you're walking through
a fire.
There's smoke everywhere.
Nuts,
Matt.
And this is in Sacramento?
Yeah.
Fuck yeah.
Is it contained now?
Sort of contained?
I mean
the one here is,
but I don't know about the one that's up
north,
but the real issue is that could happen
again like that.
Like they all,
they're all.
They sparked up so quick and more hit.
What's the plan that they could do to
make sure this doesn't happen or is
there something they can do?
I don't know.
I don't know what they can do.
What does that Jamie.
The air quality in San Francisco is so
bad.
Being there for a day is like slow
smoking.
10 cigarettes.
Fuck.
Look at that picture.
That's all.
Fire smoke where people like Western
mass,
I guess people are wearing masks.
They're like,
uh,
yeah.
Yeah.
Bert Kreischer was walking down the
street with a mask on and I.
I texted him,
what the fuck are you doing man?
He's like,
dude,
it is so bad.
It's so bad.
Here it goes.
You can't believe how smokey the era's
and there's just all through San
Francisco.
Everybody's coughing and wearing masks
in Sacramento looked even worse than
that.
It's kind of shit you never think about.
Yeah.
Well that's the thing.
It could just hit you look at that data
at San Francisco right now and if you
don't know San Francisco,
you wouldn't know how shocking this is.
Like you.
You can't see the hills.
Can't see all those houses in the hills.
It's all just smoke from the fire for
that shit to blow out.
It looks like San Francisco super like
just.
Yeah.
Hey,
is that fire contained?
A article with a couple of couple of
days ago said it was at 57 percent
contained and I was just trying to
google more.
How about that?
Only 57 percent contained at the air's a
little clear today.
They're at moderate to severe whatever.
But see,
the thing is man,
but these fires,
all it needs is one gust of wind,
one new storm,
one new Santa Ana winds pick up some
embers and then whoosh.
This whole state is just dries.
Fuck man to 80 percent,
but 80 percent contained going gonna
rain tomorrow.
Hopefully that does.
It's supposed to rain tonight,
isn't it?
It's fucking like everyone who moved out
here,
like from out East Lake when you moved
you've been here for 20 years,
20 years.
You must have been scared the first
couple of years of earthquakes,
but you never thought that,
hey,
I might have to leave my house because
of fire.
Dude,
I've been evacuated three times because
of.
Because the fire.
Yeah,
Shit.
Yeah.
How many,
how many major earthquakes since you've
been here?
None.
One minor one.
It was enough to let you know like Whoa,
like when it happens and the,
the,
the house seemed like a,
you ever get a refrigerator and you take
out that cardboard box and you stand
inside of it as a kid and you'd push it
around back and forth.
That's literally what the walls of my
apartment looked like.
Oh.
He just started moving like this.
Like it was very different than I
thought.
I thought it would be like shake,
like rumble.
Everything would shake.
No,
it was just like this dome,
Dome,
doom,
doom.
But it was so nothing.
It was a nothing earthquake.
It was like a five point or some shit or
five point seven,
but it was enough to where when the
walls moved you realize like,
Whoa,
if a big one happens,
this shit just falls apart.
Like this is not this thing.
Ain't gonna make it houses just fall
apart.
The walls would just break.
Will floor.
Were you on a second floor?
That must.
That must like if you're on the ground
floor,
you go,
okay,
I can run out the shit we can't,
but she lands in your head as you're
trying to get at,
but you know how fucking stupid humans
are.
We go like,
Nah,
I got this.
I can.
I can run out the second floor.
I think the opposite.
I was thinking if I'm going to top
floor,
I'll serve my way to the bottom.
I'll land on all these fuckers below me
a dead.
He's not going to make it.
Yeah.
It was enough to just let me just
realize like you don't even know what an
earthquake is.
Stupid.
Like my idea of an earthquake was like a
cartoon movie.
Like,
oh,
we're in an earthquake,
but a real earthquake is just the earth
shifting.
It actually moves and apparently the
people that were here during the big one
of 1993,
it was at 93,
something like that.
The earth moved almost like water,
like the.
You could see the earth just bucking and
moving and you could see like chunks of
it like lifting up and then settling
down.
The people that were there,
when you talk to them,
it's like there's,
I mean it's not ptsd like soldiers ptsd
or like rape survivors or anything,
but there's,
there's absolutely some ptsd to comes
from natural disasters.
Is this trauma to seeing how fucking
meager you are in comparison to the
earth itself as the earth is moving,
like fuck,
I got to get out of here and then a mass
exodus,
like bunch of people move to Colorado
and people moved all over the fucking
place.
Carla was nice though.
Here.
Colorado.
It's gorgeous.
Yeah.
I'm surprised at the now with the
wildfires,
are people leaving California or no?
Um,
I'm sure some are.
Yeah.
The problem is the weather's so good.
It's so nice because it never rains.
It never does anything.
You just,
you can be just a lazy bitch.
Just didn't ever have to deal with
mother nature.
Like,
well you guys live here in Montreal,
right?
Yeah.
That's no joke.
Nuts.
They're having a snow storm right now.
That cold that you guys get up there as
ruthless.
I'm going to be in Toronto in December.
Okay,
cool.
I'm there for the UFC and I know it's
going to be cold as fuck.
December it's going to have.
Plus this year is generally the winter
starts later than now and it's super
cold,
right?
Yeah.
What happened to global warming?
Global warming.
That's the first thing like those
fucking hardcore righties want to do
whereas doesn't exist.
It's slope warming.
Weird.
Where's your global warming?
Like hippies.
That simple pitch.
It's burning the fucking houses in
Malibu.
Something.
Yeah.
And that what's really funny is the chem
trail people,
they've been convinced this whole time
that the government is trying to make it
rain.
Like if ever there was a time to utilize
chem trails,
would it be now,
you know,
fuck man.
The whole thing is a,
it's very disconcerting because you
realize how fragile the whole system is
and these,
you know,
these people that worked so hard to save
everybody,
they can only save so much,
you know,
and they can only save so many
buildings.
You can only save so many people.
It's a real wake up call.
Man.
Shit could get ugly and this off topic,
but off topic of the fires,
but because,
uh,
yesterday we're talking about red band
at the store and I didn't know that when
the whole thing happened,
you were banned the whole crew for like
seven years,
like a long time.
I've talked about this too many times.
The only thing I will tell you is
because you took a bullet for the seven
years is kind of like you took a bullet
for everyone else was going to have to
deal with that shit,
but you didn't know at the time the ads
or to looking back.
I was just like,
fuck them.
Yeah.
You can say I was taking a bullet,
but I didn't think of it that way.
But yeah,
it's a thing.
The subjects beaten down too much,
you know,
we're going through it now.
That's why on our end now we have the
people who are making money by stealing
jokes.
You have that going on in France?
Yeah.
No,
it's actually a French guy was doing it.
Not with a French comedy.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
It's not in,
in Canada,
but it's in France.
And there,
uh,
there was,
I own a club in Montreal and I banded
guide this summer.
He's,
um,
he had stolen a bunch of material.
There's a thing called the GML comedy
club that it's basically like how even
when you say comedy club,
when you were saying something in French
first you have to see comedy club.
Yeah.
Okay.
So,
because that's the way you say that.
This guy,
um,
he,
he had stolen a pretty much everything
from def comedy jam and they did it
there in France and just didn't with
French language.
Even with black dudes.
Like if you're going to steal def comedy
jam,
give it to French black dudes.
Like there are black dudes in France,
but it was all these Arab guys.
So whenever you see like for uh,
10 years in France,
whatever you sign an Arab comic,
they were all like,
like Dave Chappelle.
So there was,
yeah,
there was something very fucked up.
And this summer there was,
the guy was in my club and then I found
out and I fucking lost my mind and I
just,
I,
I tweeted a,
my door guy.
And I was like,
get him the fuck out everyone.
He's with you throw them out.
I don't want them in the club strangers
thing.
Yeah.
With comedy,
you're trying to create things and some
basically a criminal can sneak in the
middle of an artist's colony and just
start profiting off of your work and
intimidating you and making you work for
them essentially.
Yeah.
There's something that sucks and people
don't know.
And that's what you went through with
when,
when you called out Carlos,
no one cares.
No one cares like they do now.
They do see the
thing is they don't know your situation
up there is different,
but the only reason they do now because
it looks good.
But if didn't like,
like,
um,
like banning Carlos now.
Like Carlos Mencia can't work anymore.
That it makes them look like we respect
comedians,
but they don't really respect Comedians,
I don't think.
Well,
who's they in this?
You sound like you're a conspiracy
theory.
They don't respect us,
man.
No,
but like whenever,
whenever I've called out a joke thieves
to,
to festivals or networks,
they're like,
okay,
yeah,
yeah.
We're gonna.
Do something about this and then as soon
as it blows over,
they don't do anything about it.
Yeah.
Well,
you're talking about festivals,
right?
You know,
I think,
um,
clubs would be much more likely to band
people,
especially if someone who they're
stealing from also works there.
That's,
that's more likely to happen.
Especially if the,
you know,
when in best case scenario the person
who's getting stolen from is already
established and successful.
So they could say something about it.
The worst case scenario,
someone who's established steals from
open microphone,
which fucking does happen.
And um,
you know,
if there's anything that you'd get
someone to quit comedy,
that might be one of them,
well,
you know,
there might be one that might be,
especially in the beginning having only
good jokes stolen by a person who does
it on television.
And then you have to watch it on comedy
central a couple days later.
You're like,
what?
And you remember that that guy had been
in the back of the room a couple of
weeks ago and watched your act and yet.
And then you're like,
what?
Like,
you can't even believe it.
There's a comic and France named a Gad
Elma lay.
Who is he?
He's in New York now and he's,
he's,
he works a lot in English.
He did a,
uh,
um,
he has these rumors and I'm going to say
allegedly because I don't want to get
to,
don't get sued.
But uh,
he,
uh,
I know that he,
he's taken a couple.
At first he took a couple bits from
American comics,
then he got caught.
So he started stealing from a French
Canadian comics.
And the last thing I heard he did was he
had this contest for open Mike
[inaudible] and he was like,
my next comedy tour,
uh,
send me your three best minutes on tape
and the best comic.
I'm going to book a top and for me.
And then he started stealing from those
open micros,
which is a,
that's such a garbage move.
It's a wacky.
Yeah.
Well,
I didn't tell them you're a good person.
Yeah,
I don't like it.
That's what I heard.
I'm not sure it's true,
but I saw him do a show once in,
in France and he was a like,
he's a rich dude.
He's,
he's got his own private plane and uh,
yeah,
he's got his own private plane.
He was,
he was married to the Princess of Monaco
so he's got a lot of money and he was
doing,
he was doing a bit,
a bit like he's just a,
he was doing a bit about how he can't
afford an air conditioner in this
apartment and I was like,
mother,
you have
a kid with the princess of Monaco.
I can afford like multiple air
conditioners.
Fuck you.
Well you know,
it's not good though.
The people care like there are people do
care.
Some people care.
Here's the thing.
The problem is saying no,
they don't get sounds like paper like
that.
All white people are racist.
You can't say it.
Yeah.
Like I know the whole thing in France a
lot.
The new generation of French French
comics are really angry about this and
there's a guy,
there's this youtube as a channel that
you talked about here when you had,
I think it was Tom Papa though is on a,
it's called copy comic and they take
like bits that they'll take a bit from a
comic from here and then they just to
show that what's going on.
But someone friends.
Yeah.
Just to educate them.
Um,
I've,
I've talked to quite a few comics from
countries that are bilingual that say
this is a.
Montreal was very bilingual.
In fact,
almost everybody speaks French,
right?
Yeah.
Uh,
yeah.
Almost everybody speaks English.
It's like probably one of the most
bilingual places and bought definitely
in Canada,
but there's not a place like that in
America.
There's no place like that in North
America now.
Even thinking North American terms of
United States,
like there's no place that's kind of
universally speaks Spanish and English,
you know,
it's like some people speak English,
some people speak Spanish,
but very few people.
I mean,
you can't this the numbers.
It's never like Montreal is like
probably probably 80 percent speak both
languages,
right?
Yeah.
That's crazy.
It's a beautiful city,
man.
It's amazing,
but you're fucking freedom of speech
laws,
dog shit.
Fuck.
Fucking didn't exist.
Well,
that's.
You're going to create shitty art when
you have that.
You know the way that you punish someone
who you think is doing something awful
with their speech.
As long as they're not calling for
someone to be murdered or something.
Right.
The way you do it,
as you don't go to their show,
you say,
I don't want to support you,
and then that's it.
You don't find them.
If enough people don't like you and your
you have a message of hate and won't
come out,
you will make money.
You're gonna,
you're gonna.
Stop doing it.
That's how you kill that.
I definitely don't think you should have
a message of hate,
but I don't think that certain people
should be able to side what's hateful
because they keep pushing that boundary
the same way.
They push all the other boundaries.
They'll push the boundaries of what,
what,
what is?
What's the definition of prejudice?
What's the definition of entitlement?
What's the definition?
You are you always coming from a place
of privilege?
So are you always entitled?
Are you always racist?
Do you.
I mean,
you know,
they have those,
they have to do this with corporations
and there's no evidence that it works at
all.
They do unconscious bias,
like counseling or they sit down with
their employees and they talked to them
about perhaps
this unconscious racism they might have.
And so everybody's like,
fuck,
am I racist?
And they'd go next.
So shitty.
It's so crazy.
But what's crazy about it is that all it
is is like they needed a response to a
perceived situation,
which I'm sure is the situation in many,
many places don't.
I'm not trying to minimalize that,
but they needed a response.
So the response to something totally
unscientific,
not support,
but at least they can say they're doing
something.
They have a,
you know,
racism bias training and they have these
people sit down and they talked to you
about like,
this is what you do.
You know,
if a person of color walks in this,
everybody's like,
Chad and I want to be racist,
but it,
I don't think it works man,
and I don't think it's,
it's not the way that racism sucks and
the way to stop racism is be a good
person.
Yeah.
Like the more good people we have,
they will inspire more good people.
We will all realize that racism is
fucking stupid and we should treat
people as individuals always.
Whether it's by gender,
my sexual preferences,
origin of your,
your ancestors.
I don't care.
I mean I care in terms of like sexual
preference,
I,
Karen terms of whether I think you're
attractive or not.
I care in terms of like whether I
decide,
you know,
the to,
like there's some people that want to
hang out with really loud people.
There's some people that want to hang
out with people that are like more
demure or some people that are more
introspect.
Everybody likes different Shit.
You're allowed to like different shit,
but you're not allowed to discriminate
against someone and keep them from
occupation or keep them from place to
live.
And if we all thought that way and just
treated people on the merits of their
own individual personality and
character,
we'd have a way better world.
I think we could all agree to that.
As soon as you get into these groups of
all white people or all Asians are all
like,
fucking come on man.
That's too small.
That's such a gross generalization.
It's too small of a common denominators
to weird the what,
what you are like,
how much of what you are is where the
fuck you're from and shit,
you can't control how much melanin you
have in your skin.
That's ridiculous.
What you are is all the things you've
experienced and all the life you've
lived and all the lessons you've learned
where you are at this moment.
You know.
And if I like you at 30,
I might not apply to you when you were
18.
You might've been fucking annoying.
But I meet you when you're 30.
And I'm like hey,
you're cool.
You know,
and everything's great.
And that should be okay too.
It's not like we have to distinguish
between people just being not interested
in talking to any one individual and
what is wrong with with gross
generalizations and then tribal ideas of
like sticking to only people of European
ethnicity and these are the good folks
of European descent,
like you're fucking crazy.
Civilization's been down that road
stupid.
You can't do that shit again and you
can't do it for Asians either.
You can't do it for black people.
You can't do it for anything.
You can't say everybody's great in this
group because it's nonsense.
It's so simplistic.
It's not just simplistic,
it's dangerous,
and it also makes people scared to say
anything about like,
I don't want you to think of that.
I hate the thing.
I left blank.
The thing I like about not censoring
hate speech is if you let hateful people
say hateful things,
you know where the dangerous people are.
So if you're censoring like you can't
use this where you can't say this.
You can't say that.
You don't know who the fucking Weirdos
are at that hate black people.
They hate gay people that hate the
translator because everyone's acting
exactly the same.
Like everything's cool,
and then when they're with their friends
or whoever,
the people that that think like them,
then they're buting all their fucking
hate and shit and garbage.
Well,
whenever people can express themselves
freely,
there's going to be some sort of
suppression and if there's some sort of
suppression,
there is a resentment of that
suppression.
And then there's just like this anxiety
and this tension.
You know,
it's like when he would.
It's essentially what we're saying is
when you think about people in business
meetings,
how they're forced to communicate,
how this forced to address how they're
forced to communicate that go into this
very professional building.
All the women are dressed professional,
all the men to dress professional.
They all get together in these
conference tables and everyone is
agreeing.
Even those,
these are sexual beings who may be like
cocaine,
you know,
and they,
they've been fucking,
you know,
that they,
they've,
they've been to music festivals and
they've maybe been to burning man and,
but they're contained that contained in
this room and they're talking about
statistics and talking about
probabilities and then someone brings up
diversity.
Yes.
Diversity,
all very important and everyone is
behaving and this super weird world
where you can't,
you can't move outside the box even
remotely if you,
if you move outside the box even a
little,
if you say you know about the guy from
Netflix that got fired because he used
the n word in a descriptive.
He was,
he was talking about Tom Segura special.
We're Thompson was talking about changes
in language and just talked about some
words can't say anymore and he says
like,
you can't say retarded.
He says this just because he said that
just because he said that people were
getting angry at him and protesting and
groups.
We're trying to boycott Netflix,
remember?
Right.
So this guy,
I don't remember his name,
but he was one of the big wigs at
Netflix and he said he was like,
it's like saying the word nigger to an
African American person.
That's what it's like to say retarded to
a family where someone has someone who's
downstairs.
So he was defending,
he was talking about how offensive that
word is to people.
So I was like,
this is the issue that we're dealing
with.
So you just talked about it at a very
matter of fact way.
They report him for saying the word and
he gets fired and apparently he did this
twice.
This is what I've read in the same
context.
Yes.
The same
exact context.
So he's repeating this thought.
It's basically having a.
they're doing an intellectual exercise
like is this,
is it the same to you?
And he's saying it around African
American people,
but in saying it around African American
people,
just the fact that he said the word
uttered it like Abracadabra.
Just saying it was enough for him to
lose his very high profile job at
Netflix was apparently well liked.
And it really.
Do you think we're becoming like this
because our lives are too easy?
That like if we had to struggle to get
food and and protect our families,
we wouldn't be worried about this word
or that word or my feelings.
One hundred percent.
Yeah.
I think we're.
We're,
we're seeking out altercations when we.
Because I think we're programmed for a
certain amount of interaction with
people that's unpleasant.
We're,
we're,
we're a program for a certain amount of
competition,
whether it's verbal or physical.
We're programmed for it.
I think it's what got us to 2018 in
terms of the crazy history of the human
species is it marched across the world.
So imagine leaving Africa.
What woody got animal skins on your feet
and you're walking out.
What the fuck were those people and what
kind of people they encounter?
That's our ancestors.
Our ancestors had just been dealing with
bullshit forever and when there's no
bullshit,
there's some bullshit over there.
There's 78 different gender pronouns
motherfucker.
And the reason why you don't think so
because you're a cis gendered white
privilege piece of Shit and all white
people are racist.
And then you start tweeting up a storm,
those if you go to those people's pages,
one of the things that I,
I'll,
I'll find a person who says like
preposterous shit and if I'm not blocked
by them from some gigantic autoblocker,
which sometimes they do these block
everybody.
But if someone I'm not blocked by them,
I will bookmark them.
So instead of like following them so
they know I'm from,
I would just bookmark them so I'll just
go back.
So I have a file on my computer called
crazy motherfuckers and I will go the
crazy motherfuckers page and I'll see
them go through these manic depressive
states and freak out about the world.
And then every now and then something
will get tossed in there about
relationships.
You know?
I mean yeah,
because I know,
I know it is,
it is harder for someone of color like a
black or Arab or you know,
Asian around some people around some
people.
Yeah.
But saying white privilege,
like there are a lot of white homeless
men.
And whenever I say a white homeless
dude,
I always want to give them money and go
white,
white privilege do.
There's no doubt there's an advantage in
this current climate and world to being
white.
The problem is the white people are not
guilty of doing anything just because
they're privileged,
right?
So instead of calling it white
privilege,
well we need to concentrate on is the
people that are racist.
That's the only real problem.
The only problem is racist people.
And even though white people get
discriminated against less,
the problem was saying things like black
people can't be racist because racism is
a power thing and bite people have power
over black people.
That's it's.
It's a
fucking intellectual forest.
They know it is when they're saying it
and it's just one thing that they just
repeat and you're supposed to accept it.
And it's a part of what we were talking
about earlier where there's a game
that's going on and the game is,
I want you to say the 78 different
gender pronouns I want you to say that I
want you to do that.
I want you to refer to me is that I want
you to for to me is this.
I want you to do what I want you to do.
Once you stop using certain language,
I want you to start saying certain
things because that means I win.
It's counterproductive because you're
not teaching anyone how stupid it is to
just discriminate based on race.
All you're doing is blocking out that.
Being honest.
I think that that doesn't even work
anyway.
I think what really works is leading by
example.
I think that's the only thing that
works.
What I think we learned from what we've
learned from people better than us.
You see someone who is amazing and she's
super smart and she's really kind to
people who got,
damn it.
I got to be more like her.
I think that's where we're missing that
aspect of it.
The chastising.
See this is the problem with what goes
on with the left in particular,
the brutal mean assaults on people.
These twitter gangs and facebook gangs,
they target someone and attack them.
You are not changing anything and in
fact you are going to get people who see
this horrible shit and they're going to
go,
fuck those people.
I'm going that way,
and they go the other way and you
recruit people to be on the right,
and this is literally how Donald Trump
became president.
One of the,
one of the major factors was people were
noticing a trend and the trend was
towards these crybaby,
preposterous liberals that call it
everything is racist.
Everything is sexist.
Everything is homophobic.
Everything and everything falls into
this blanket of transgression where
there's no innocent and everyone's
guilty and then when they find they run
out of targets,
they go after each other for not being
progressive enough to start calling each
other out to find jealousy in the
movement.
That's something that really makes me
happy when I see people that have been
calling people out for years and then
they get caught out and I'm like,
fuck,
finally.
Well,
you know,
I've seen it happen.
I've seen it.
I've seen it happen with people I've
seen.
I've seen them become.
Jamie Kilstein is a friend of mine and
Jamie Kilstein was at one point in his
life this really progressive activist
guy who was like,
everything he said had to be like super
male feminists and super trans positive
and I mean he was trying so hard to be
accepted but,
but he's super honest about it too.
He's done a podcast about it and you
know,
he'd call people out and be really mean
and really vicious.
And then he realized he was getting all
this anxiety from it.
He had to check his twitter all day.
He'd be walking the street,
just couldn't stop,
like checking his twitter,
see what their replies were.
And he was released.
He was caught in this weird fucking hate
spiral,
you know,
even though he was proporting,
he was acting on the premise that he was
a good person and he was going to call
out all these bad people,
but he was like addicted to this
weirdness.
And then it turned on him.
It turned on him like some girls accused
him of being creepy and it was like
super minor,
like trying to go on dates with people
like just.
But that was enough that it all you need
is like one in that world,
every in that world,
everyone is so hyper progressive and
looking for any sort of deviation from
the pattern they can attack and they
just decided that this guy,
even though he had been like this model
ally for,
for a male as a male feminist and for
people of color and gay stood for
everything that they wanted to.
He's a piece of garbage because he's
heterosexual,
you know,
and you know,
apparently he worked with this girl or
something like that,
but whatever it was,
I mean it was the most minor of
transgressions.
There was no rape,
no touching,
no,
no meanness know,
like.
And so after all this was done,
he came out on the other end and that it
needed just came clean about like how he
felt while he was doing it.
Why did.
It was very brave that he did that.
But it gives you insight to a lot of
like what is one of the problems of this
unnavigable territory of social media is
that it's very compelling to engage
constantly and consistently with people
in this,
this really anxiety ridden wave of
animosity that's going to run back and
forth between the two of you for no
reason.
Most of the time for no reason
was free.
The Nipple,
a big thing here.
There was more New York like a lot of
gals were.
They decided they were going to protest,
that men can be topless but they can be
topless and they passed that right?
I,
I had a friend that she was telling me
and we had this conversation and she was
like,
no,
but like a female female,
breasts aren't sexual,
so I should be allowed to shop.
And I was like,
look,
you know that I know that my penis
doesn't know.
I'm sorry if I see tits.
My Dick is going to get hard.
I'm sorry.
It's not like I respect you,
but if,
if you fucking pull your tits out,
my Dick is going to get hard.
We get,
we do.
We do for you,
we were animals,
but you know,
it's also that we're just not used to
seeing tits.
Yeah.
If tits were out all the time,
they were actually get used to it.
The problem is changing gears.
Look at those people in that fucking
dead island.
They have weird tits.
Tits.
Someone needs to tell them they need
nice west coast to the west coast.
Yeah.
I don't know man.
I think they should be able to do it
though.
They want to walk around topless,
but the problem is there's too many
dickheads.
You're.
You're running into a river of
dickheads.
You're going to try to go upstream
through that with her tits hanging out.
That's fucking true.
You go to a bar,
if you want to go to a bar top lists
like,
look,
that is chaos that's going off the
rails.
Yeah,
you definitely should be able to do it,
but I don't think you should.
If you were my friend.
Like I said,
if in an ideal world should be able to,
yes,
you should definitely be able to,
but do I think you should do it?
No,
no,
don't do that.
People are going to try to suck them.
They're going to try to grab them.
It's like it's.
If someone's going
to touch your tits,
it's good.
It's so rare.
You have to be in the perfect bar in
Asheville,
North Carolina,
and you can be there from 10 to two and
nobody will touch your tits like one
place.
Someone's gonna touch your tits.
People are gross.
Like even even when girls,
Ariana Grande Grande's sang at aretha
Franklin's funeral.
Even that preacher tried to touch her
test.
He was going to grip.
Yeah.
So imagine if she had freed the nipple
fucking crazy.
He would have gotten who'd got pregnant.
But there's,
there's no argument in saying that they
shouldn't do that.
Right?
It shouldn't be a law.
This is almost like mean you can make
parallels to compelled speech because I
don't think that you should be naked and
just walk down the street if you're a
girl,
but you should be allowed.
I don't think you should if you're my
friend because I would say,
listen,
you're going to get harassed.
It's is way more likely that you'll get
raped,
I would think.
I mean,
I'd like to know what the,
I don't want to do a study,
but I would like to know what the
statistics look just make,
make these people get raped,
like just walk around for four of our
subjects,
got raped.
You don't want,
don't want to do that study.
But um,
I think um,
if you live in a tribe like that
uncontacted tribe outside of India,
they're probably super accustomed to
seeing people naked and it's,
they probably act normal.
It's probably not that big a deal where
we're,
you know,
it's like,
what's in the box man?
What's in the box?
And we will cover everything up.
But the buys are all covered up or feed
or whatever.
Remember,
remember when we were young,
like I'd see just a sears catalog,
a woman in a bra and I jerk off and now
like it desensitized.
You start watching porn and then you're
like,
oh fuck.
If someone had Mascara running,
it's not gagging.
It's,
there isn't at least one murder in this.
How can I get hard?
Watch an action movie and nobody dies in
a bitch ass movies this.
But we're Weirdos.
And everybody has their own weird quirk.
It's I think a lot of times we don't
admit it or we then you see someone who
an extreme and you're like,
oh fuck.
At least I'm out that like we have an
intern for for our podcast and he's hard
to gold.
Right?
But he has a crippling addiction of
prostitutes and just a weird guy,
like when you meet him,
he's just a fucking over the top.
Weird.
Is it crippling because you can't afford
it.
He's a weird.
But he just said bad judge of character.
So He.
He picks all hookers that will steal
money.
He got robbed the other day.
We've been here for two days.
He was robbed and pepper sprayed.
She made a documentary on this guy.
We're going to talk about it for awhile.
Pro on this motherfucker.
You can get that party role and that's
what you do.
You blur out faces and watch.
What's his name?
Poseidon.
Poseidon gets his ass kicked by the name
of the name of
the documentary.
And it'd be your version of the naked
woman walking around trying to knock it,
right?
Yeah.
The way he told the story,
like he was like,
he,
he talked to this woman and we were
like,
that's not a real picture.
You're the shit you're going to get.
She's going to steal,
she's going to steal all your shit.
And he was like,
no,
I think she's real.
Or like,
oh,
she's not real.
And then she came over to the house when
we were doing a spot at the,
at the store.
And uh,
she,
she told them it's 300,
he gave her $300.
Then he tried to touch her and she was
like,
no,
it's 300 just to meet,
we need more money.
And then they went out to a,
like an ATM.
He got more money,
gave her the money,
she brought it.
She went back to the apartment and then
he pulled the Dick and she was like,
no,
we're not having sex.
And then he was like,
what?
And then she,
she ran away and pepper sprayed or like
she ran it,
he was still making it.
So he said I tried to chase her,
but she was fast in the hills and
there's two flights of stairs and he
slipped on the last ones because he has
his boxer shorts and as soon as he stood
up from the slip,
she sprayed him in the face.
She ran out,
he ran three floors up to get dressed.
And then you went out looking for her.
But he's not gonna find finer.
And then he shows up at the store.
Belligerent.
And was he naked when she pepper sprayed
him?
Yeah.
Uh,
well,
from what he told us,
his boxers were stuck on his foot.
What?
When,
when he told us a story,
we were like,
I get,
I get why she pepper sprayed you.
Cause you're like,
he's a,
like,
he's a big dude.
And Poseidon is like fucking like 300
pounds,
six five.
And she's a singer.
She's got a guy that's like 350 pounds
with a rock hard dick going,
you fucking whore.
He was yelling.
I know him.
So he definitely said that.
And we were worried because the airbnb
that the owner lives right behind.
And she's very nosy,
she's nosy bitch.
She keeps looking at what we're doing.
So I'm like fuck,
she's hearing this.
And she said,
be quiet.
No glitter in the house,
like weird rules litter.
And I think we broke every rule,
environmental person saying you
shouldn't use glitter anymore.
It gets to the fish.
Oh,
is that why she said the ocean?
Because we didn't know why.
It was like,
what?
No glitter.
Like who asks like,
why am I was like you walk,
you litter off the glitter goes into the
drain.
But glitter adventure,
he gets into the water.
Why would,
like I told her we're going to be three
dudes renting the apartment.
Why would we bring glitter?
Or maybe this is la.
Yeah,
no man.
You were gone on before about you.
Not.
It's impossible for you to be a gay guy.
You definitely could have been gay guy,
a gay burlesque.
But even if I was a gay guy,
like I wouldn't.
I wouldn't be a gay guy,
I don't think would bro.
Man,
high heels,
fishing nets,
glitter.
He'd go hard.
Hard.
And you'd have like some old timey
clothes onto like a Charlie Chaplin Gay
guy like Sherlock Holmes.
Yeah,
man.
Old Timey,
Charlie,
Charlie Chaplin,
gay stuff.
You know how,
how hard it must have been in those days
to be gay.
Like coming out of the closet now.
It's still hard in small towns.
But imagine already even in big cities,
man.
Depends on your friend's parents.
Yeah.
Yeah man.
Charlie Chaplin.
Days Imagine.
But there's probably a lot of gang shit
going on.
Like I don't think there's any
difference in the number.
I bet the numbers probably sound like
this.
It's exactly the same.
I'm sure.
Yeah.
Cause even now people are saying now
there are more,
there are more transit in the weather,
but there are more that are getting
operations.
But in the old days it was the same
thing.
I'm sure.
Yeah.
I bet the numbers consistent.
Probably the percentage.
It's probably more numbers now because
there's more people.
There were probably a bunch of gay dudes
from the fifties that were actually
trans women,
but just because you couldn't get,
you couldn't change anything,
so you just suck Dick,
you know,
in private or whatever.
This is science.
I'm a scientist book on this.
Got a deep passion for this information.
So you guys are on compound media.
It's called a.
it's called and drink minimum.
We do shows.
Do you have two drinks?
And every show will have more than we
do.
Always have two drink minimum.
Yeah.
And we do have done a one drink show.
No,
but we do,
we do one shots which are,
we do free episodes,
like just on itunes once a week,
30 minute show.
And then on Fridays we do the two hour
show on compound media and it's just a
compound mediums,
which is a nd Anthony Kumi is a thing.
And Anthony,
um,
he's so fucking funny.
He's a genius.
He most people know him.
He's such a wild man too.
So crazy.
And Anthony,
if it wasn't open,
anthony wasn't for open.
Anthony podcast wouldn't exist.
Like the format podcasting.
Every and now they're really good.
Podcast,
but the first couple of years of
podcasts,
like 2006,
seven,
whatever,
most podcasts sounded like shitty
versions of Opie and Anthony and now
like,
like was ones that we're trying to do
like an hour long interview style
podcast.
It was more like a,
you know,
some npr type deal or something like
that.
And then um,
we started doing,
um,
where there would be like a lot of
comics just hanging around,
hanging out and when,
when we started doing those,
which was like 2009 ish,
that was clearly influenced by opie and
anthony and also influenced even more so
by Anthony Kumi is Internet show that he
was doing last compound show?
Yeah.
Yeah,
because I watched that and this is one
of the big things that hit me because I
realized I could do it because um,
he just set it up in his basement.
I mean,
he,
he had some money and he decided to make
a green screen and you've got these
professional cameras.
And then I thought about it while I was
watching them.
I was like,
why don't I do that?
I'm like,
why am not doing that?
Like he's got this whole setup in his
basement and then there was this one
time where he was drunk doing karaoke
with a machine gun as,
as you get a machine gun,
any sig,
and he's doing karaoke and I remember
thinking like this crazy motherfucker I
need to,
I need to do a show now.
I need to because now I'm saying this
would be a lot of fun and I always
enjoyed doing radio shows when I did
them.
I would do.
I'm like,
I would do opie and anthony even if I
didn't have like tickets to sell,
even if it was all sold out,
I would still show up and go hang out
with those guys because it was just fun.
Like a comic's table.
Like it was just hanging out.
Just break them both.
I like this.
I mean like we're doing right now.
That's how it happened.
You know,
I'm doing it with those guys and
watching anthony do it on his own and
becoming friends with Jimmy,
you know?
And then seeing how it's fun to just
hang out with comics.
You did Anthony show a couple of weeks
ago,
couple weeks ago,
but it hasn't aired yet.
I don't think it's holding on to it to
next week when he's,
uh,
he's actually going to be here because
the third is,
is new sidekick.
Uh,
Dave Landau is fucking insanely funny.
He's really,
really,
really funny comic.
Yeah.
He's a comic from Detroit who now now
lives in New York and I didn't know him.
And like every,
all of the open anthony fans were like,
fuck,
why?
Why didn't he,
I have Jamie.
Why doesn't he have Jimmy?
Why doesn't he have a.
Why doesn't,
why doesn't own,
ain't get back together.
But Dave Landau and grant money.
You Go,
okay,
this works.
This is a very good company.
Really good show.
Yeah.
He's a super nice guy too.
First Smart Dude.
And um,
their setup is great.
You know,
the green screen behind them just turns
it into whatever the fuck he wants it to
be.
And He's got a little stadium seating.
So all the weird people.
So something fun though about when his
shell,
like the first couple of times I did his
show when it was in the basement of his
house.
There's something I like about doing
those shows when you're,
you're,
you go into someone's house.
Like I did Steven crowder show,
uh,
like a month ago and there was something
cool about going in the suburbs of
Dallas in his garage to do his show.
Supposed to say where he lives,
man.
Guys hiding.
No,
but yeah.
But tell us.
I'm sorry.
I even crowder dies my fault.
I was getting blamed tooth moved around
a lot.
Yeah.
No,
I know y'all.
Yeah,
that's true.
But remember he did that a thing that
Bob Ross Paints Muhammad to.
I took ball.
Yeah.
I mean it's literally something that
they're allowed to kill you if you do.
And he did that allowed.
Yeah,
I mean it's strange time.
I mean this is a,
also a time where that,
criticizing that,
criticizing anything that's Islamic is
very dangerous because people call you
Islamophobic and because people want to
kill you.
So we've got two different things going
on at the same time.
But those same people will have no
problem mocking Christians.
I am.
Yeah.
I'm,
I'm
not even like,
I'm not a right wing guy.
I consider myself a little more to the
left,
but there's something I like about right
wing media,
especially like the funny type of right
wing media that they take fucking crazy
risks.
You mean like Kumina,
like,
like Kumina,
like crowder,
like A.
Steven crowder is really funny to like
Gavin McInnes I think is fucking
hilarious.
Gavin's in the crossfire and right now
is the eye of Sauron is upon him.
He's too much stupid shit about inciting
violence.
And now that there's some articles
saying that the FBI considers him a,
that the proud boys are hate group.
But then Kumina sent me something that
he sent him and I'll send it to you.
He's saying it's
bullshit.
The first time I heard about the proud
boys I was doing Gavin shown New York
and uh,
he,
he was with a Dante narrow,
which is a,
a black comic in New York.
And he was like,
Hey,
uh,
the,
me and him are in the proud boys.
And I was like,
what the fuck's the proud boys holding?
Let's explain what it actually is.
Because a joke,
at first it was like,
we don't jerk off,
so the will want to fuck our wives.
And then like four months later I was
like,
oh
Gavin McInnes quit the proud boys today.
Well,
you know,
Oh,
is it today?
I thought he had quit that years ago
though.
This just got posted.
I think.
Think maybe Jamie,
I'm sending you an article to where he's
realizing how problematic it is to be
connected with these people.
And you know,
look,
it's one of those fucking things.
You want to have a group,
you can't control everyone in the group.
So anybody in the group that does
something horrible.
I just sent you something.
Pull this up.
This is Gavin's response to all this
because so many people got mad at me
that I had Gavin on the first place.
First of all I had Gavin on because used
to be one of the founders of vice also
because I had Gavin on before that and
he was fun to hang out with.
Then when I had them on,
I've had them on the last time.
One of the things that he was talking
about was the proud boys.
I didn't even know what the fuck that
was.
I think maybe I'd heard of it,
but I thought it was a joke.
Turned out he used to be a joke.
It started off as a joke on compound
media and Anthony will get into a
better.
He knows the history of it,
but they were making fun of something
and they decided to make a fake mock
group called the proud boys.
Now the problem with this is when you
have a group that's supposed to be
fighting and the va and I actually tried
to express this to him when he was on
the show because he was talking about
kicking people's ass.
We're going to punch him in the face.
I'm telling them to punch people in the
face.
I'm like,
okay,
that's not how reality works.
Like,
I don't know if you've ever been punched
in the face or if you've been around
people that like to punch people in the
face,
but you don't just punch someone in the
face.
What happens is you punched him in the
face,
they come back with a bat,
somebody gets a knife,
people get guns.
It always escalates.
It's going to keep going.
You don't just get away with punching
people in the face,
you know,
and yeah,
it's not good that these antifa people
bring bike locks and smack people in the
heads with them and that's kind of the
point in that in the first place.
Those people don't understand what
happens when you start the chain of
violence.
When you started that domino.
They don't understand what happens.
They think that they're living in some
fucking book that they love about some
revolutionary liberal character that
reaches out and and smashes all these
oppressors of social justice.
That's not reality and reality.
You just hit a guy with a lock,
was talking to you,
you assaulted him with a deadly weapon,
and the next thing you know they're
going to kill you or they're going to
beat you.
They're going to punch you.
So when a guy like Gavin says something
like,
you should punch them in the face.
I understand why he said that because
they were inciting violence.
These,
these antifa people would hit people
with things that were in masks.
They,
some of them,
some of them were doing it nonviolently.
Some of them just wanted what they
thought was the right things to happen.
But like all groups,
you get a fucking big group.
You can't control everybody in the
group.
And that happened with the proud boys
too,
I think.
I think he decided to have this thing
that was going to,
you know,
mockingly oppose Antifa.
Then it became real and then it became
violence.
And just this is.
This is just one of the problems that
people have when there's a fucking group
of people have post to another group of
people and you know,
him quitting the proud boys is
definitely smart.
But I don't think it's going to help
because now people are saying he's a
white supremacist and what the
perception that people have of you is
almost important,
almost as important as what you actually
do.
It's probably even more important almost
because not for you and not for me,
not for people that are gonna actually
read into it,
but for people in the outside,
the perception of who you are,
is it just too many things to learn?
Okay,
he's a racist.
Oh fuck that racist.
That's all people here.
That's all they say.
And then they keep moving.
Meanwhile you've got a guy who's Gavin
who,
first of all,
he's not even American.
He's Canadian.
Second of all,
he's married to a native American woman.
He is not a racist.
He said he's a provocateur.
One hundred percent.
Unquestionably.
He says ridiculous shit because he
thinks it's funny,
but he's a very bad situation.
Is almost a troll or like.
I didn't even think like I've,
I know him,
like we're not good,
good friends.
But I,
I,
I liked them a lot and I'm pretty sure
he's not even right wing.
I think he's just fucking,
he's definitely fucking with people and
he definitely has some right wing ideas,
but more than that,
he doesn't like some of the ridiculous
aspects of the left,
so it's more in.
It's again,
like he's a more opposed some of the
more preposterous notions of relapsed
and he is really right.
Yeah,
but he's right on some things to a right
wing on some things,
but he came onto the show dressed like
fucking Michael Douglas from falling
down as a goof.
He brought a freezer case and everything
or a tie and a white short sleeve button
up shirt.
He did it as a goof.
Like that's him.
He's a.
he's a weird guy.
Is Funny.
He says funny shit,
but he.
But in this,
when you.
There's two different ways you can go
through life,
right?
He could pretend,
put on an act or you can be yourself.
What he's chosen to do is a little bit
of both.
He's chosen
to pretend a little bit but also be
himself,
so it's hard for people to know where
the line is.
That's fun.
If you're getting away with it.
It's not fun when it turns on you and
then you go,
no,
that part I was joking around about
people like says who like who's who's
right and who's wrong.
Like it gets.
It gets real slippery when people don't
actually know who you are,
where you stand.
And I think he was,
he thought it was fun to fuck with
people a little bit on with certain
things and in this climate man that can
be fucking dangerous.
Yeah,
definitely.
And Kaufman of 2018.
No he's not.
He's a different thing.
He's,
he's Gavin McInnes,
you know,
and I really,
I'm sad that all this shit is going down
and I hope it passes over and,
and people get to understand me.
It's not a perfect person,
but no one is.
But what he has is an interesting guy.
He was weird.
Says Funny Shit.
Did he take a shit on the air once on a
show?
He stuck his finger up his ass and shit
up.
He's not a bad guy.
He's a maniac.
Yeah.
If there's something we're right now
going on,
like in 2018 that the left hates or
right the right hates the left and we're
all exactly the same.
Or you know,
a difference between what you said.
Yes.
The stupidity in the group.
Just the whole group.
I'm going to hate.
Exactly like the worst common
denominator.
The worst common denominator.
The worst actors in any group define
that group.
So whether it's,
you know,
people that are on the right.
Look,
there's a lot of people who are on the
right whore,
fiscally conservative but socially
liberal and they just,
they just don't think that you should
spend money like crazy and they believe
in discipline and they believe and you
know,
having an intelligent financial
planning,
you know,
and there's,
there's that as well as people who are
socially democratic socialist.
I think you could spend all the rich
people's money on all these other
things.
There's just as many people because
they're like,
there's a way broader spectrum,
but you have to pick a side.
I think most of us are like 90 percent
in the metal and then there's the five
five on each side that like,
you're like,
no,
I'm more left leaning and then you see
like extreme left and you're like,
what the fuck is wrong with these
people?
Okay,
I'm more right.
And then you see the fucking Weirdos on
the right.
You're like,
what the fuck?
Like there's something very scary on
both sides.
Yeah.
And when you see that scary thing,
you want to pose that thing.
So you become what?
It's the op,
you know,
you become a left wing person,
you decided,
well we've got to stop trump no matter
what.
Whatever is never trump.
I mean there was a lot of that going on.
I think the only reason why I went more
to the right side is because of the free
speech thing,
because I think pretty much everything.
I'm more left leaning except the free
speech thing that I'm more right
leaning.
It's insane.
It shouldn't be a writer left thing.
Well,
it's insane.
To me that's the left that's having a
problem with free speech.
That's what's insane to me because I
always thought the left was all about
free expression and intelligence and
education and it used to be,
it also used
to be more about peaceful behavior,
like the hippies in the,
you know,
the seventies where everything really
changed in the sixties,
which really did launch a revolution and
changed a lot of America during the
sixties,
in the seventies.
And a lot of it is inspired by
psychedelic drugs.
Right?
All those people,
man,
but nonviolent.
That was a big part of that whole
movement was all love,
you know,
and the hippies movement of today is not
the same.
It's like a feeble,
small subset of the overall aggressive
liberal group,
you know,
that thinks that,
they've got to stomp out sexism and
racism and transphobia and all these
things and like really aggressive front
running,
you know,
the ones who want to change policy and
change culture and change society.
So when you get and teeth involved and
you get people screaming in people's
faces and people going to lectures and
blocking lectures and threatening
violence and like,
wow,
this is a very different kind of vibe.
Then what changed the world in 67?
I used to have a bit about how the best
way to deal with hate is with love and
that I truly believed that if someone
like w and I try to do that.
Like it was weird when I was going
through my weird face,
but now whenever people say I fucking
hate you because you did this,
you did this.
I tried to understand why they hate me
to.
And I generally do understand like I'm
not a fucking idiot.
So I know,
okay.
Yeah,
I,
I'm,
I'm a guy that made fun of a disabled
boy.
I get,
I get how you can hate that.
But then I try,
I try to,
you know,
instead of going,
fuck you,
I'm allowed doing this.
I show them respect.
I show them love.
And then after like three minutes,
they're always like,
oh no.
Yeah,
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry if I told you you shouldn't do
that.
No,
you shouldn't.
I,
it's so easy to change people's minds
just by listening to people.
Some.
No,
it's,
it's also probably as like,
these people don't know you.
They're just engaging with you to get a
reaction out of people.
One,
it's not just some people are what is
some people,
but most people,
if you're one on one in real life on,
on the Internet,
on facebook,
on twitter,
it's really hard to change how people
think.
But if you've talked to people and you
realize,
okay,
this guy's not a month and this guy is
not an asshole.
Because whenever people want to like,
like if,
if,
if you,
some guy that doesn't like you on the
Internet that goes,
uh,
Joe Rogan's a fucking asshole.
If,
if you met him,
he wouldn't say that.
And,
and if he did think you were an asshole,
he'd explained this is what I think.
And then you'd talked to him and he'd be
like,
oh no,
Joe Rogan's a good guy.
Listen,
there's,
there's definitely a limited amount that
you could get through when you're
expressing yourself on twitter,
on instagram or something like that and
people like to get reactions out of
people so they want to get Mike Ward's
goat,
they're going to fuck with you and say
mean shit to you,
and they're doing it because they want
to get a reaction and some of them don't
even think of you as a and they also
think of you as an easy target because
you did something mean and because
you're a guy in the public eye and
you're a professional comedian and maybe
they hate their job and like,
fuck this guy.
Is he living his dream when I have to do
the Shitty job?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That's a lot of it.
So it's a Shitty,
it's a Shitty,
but b,
you don't really know because the whole,
the whole interaction sucks.
Like he's wrong,
you're wrong.
Everybody's wrong.
Though.
The whole thing is stupid and
interacting with people like that and
going back and forth with them.
I've done it before.
It's stupid to do,
but it's just a complete waste of
energy.
Did you get along shit,
your last special?
No,
no shit,
no fucking article from vegans,
but then ms dot quoted because they
totally took me out of context because
they said he calls vegans dip shits.
That's not what I said.
What I said was that the majority of
Vegans I think are good people who are
just trying to live their lives without
something dying.
They just made this moral choice and
then I say,
and those people pay for it with their
health.
They're always sick.
Fuck up.
He looked like what the other job,
the other part of the job.
The other part of the joke was he used
to like the other part of the joke was
I'm in the rest of the people that are
Vegan there really only vegan because
scientology didn't find them first.
I go there,
fucking dip shits.
They coulda woulda joined the Taliban if
they took the wrong exit.
It's just so the took out.
He calls vegans dip shits.
No,
no,
that's not what I said,
but that's the title of the article.
That's the only thing that I feel like
you're special.
I'm sure there's other things to thing
about vegans.
I spent like four hours looking at
pictures of people that have vacant
cats.
That was like when when like I don't eat
meat or I don't eat meat product,
but my dogs I'm like,
cats do because like why am I going to
decide?
Like I feel guilty if I eat steak,
but my fucking dog doesn't care my dog.
If I left my dog out of the house
without me,
he'd fucking kill everything,
so why am I going to be like,
no,
no young man.
You're going to eat carrots.
I know dogs can be vegan without
swallowing hina,
but cats can't die like in a month and a
half.
Yeah.
That's why I wrote that,
but I didn't even know that people were
that stupid,
that they.
They made their cats Vegan and then just
looking at the pictures,
there's something weird that like,
I think all vegetarian and Vegans,
if you look at animal cruelty,
you're always sad.
But when I was looking at Vegan cats,
it made me laugh.
I was like,
what the fuck?
It's so ridiculous,
so stupid because it's such a fucking
glaringly ridiculous proposition.
Decide that a cat is no longer a
carnivore.
They all looked freddy mercury
the last month of his life.
I don't know if Freddy Mercury was the
last one.
Is Google a Vegan.
Cats need to see that
on his deathbed.
I don't need to see it.
I get it.
Yeah.
God Damn you made me feel like shit.
That was a good joke.
And I was like,
Oh,
I'm a bad person.
I thought maybe there was a real photo
going around.
Oh,
the probably is that I've been through
is.
Yeah,
it's um.
I don't know,
man.
If you,
if you can explain your comedy well
today,
you can still get away with a lot,
but you just have to,
you have to take a lot of time to craft
your bits and you gotta think about what
you're saying and how other people,
not just whether or not it works because
sometimes things work,
but you're saying things like,
oh,
I could have got away with the same
exact thought and I would've been.
I would've been in more people's brains.
It would have gotten in smoother.
I did,
uh,
the,
I heard a thing,
I love Norm Mcdonald.
Look,
Norm Macdonald's,
my favorite comic of all time.
And He,
when I was going through my thing,
I saw a thing about him that he said
that when he was doing weekend update,
he'd done a joke about someone that had
just died and then he got an email from
the,
the people's family about her.
It was before email.
So I guess he got a letter of facts or
whatever about the,
how they felt about that joke.
And he was like,
that made me realize that,
oh shit,
when I make fun of someone,
there's an actual person behind that
joke.
There's.
And that,
what it,
it's weird that my,
my whole court thing,
uh,
like,
like when I was,
this was before I went to court,
I read norms thing and I was like,
oh fuck,
I never got that because I was doing
jokes about this.
This kid was famous.
So in my mind it was like making fun of
Justin Bieber was like making fun of
whoever,
whoever.
But then I realized,
Oh fuck,
there's,
there's someone behind,
you know,
someone that feels
what you're saying is exactly what
people experience when they hate on you
online.
Yeah.
Oh,
it's exactly the same thing.
They don't think of you as being a
person just the same way.
You don't think of Justin Bieber as
being a person.
Exactly.
It's the same thing.
Yeah.
We're all guilty of it.
I think.
I mean,
I hope ultimately we were going to get
past this.
I think a lot of what's happening with
this is that this has only been around
for like 20 years,
this internet way of communicating with,
with each other and only been around the
way it is really the way it is now for
like less than 10.
Yeah.
You know,
and I think that we don't know what
we're doing with it yet.
We don't know how to do it yet and we
fuck it up.
And I think too,
like for comedy for a while when I was
going through my thing,
everyone is telling me they're like,
do you think this is the death of like
dark humor?
And,
and I don't think it is,
but I think we're gonna just be smarter
about,
no,
you gotta get the fuck out of Canada.
But also,
I mean this is what everybody always.
This is the end.
This is the end of this.
I mean that was one of the things that I
read about the Nanette special.
This is the end of comedy.
Like she was gonna kill comment.
Like you never going to be at the end
there,
but it's so silly.
Like why would someone not want to
laugh?
It doesn't mean that it's not a good
piece of art,
but why would someone not want to laugh?
I then there was another weird thing
that she got interviewed and she said
that she was going to retire unless
Louis ck comes back and he does.
He comes back,
he comes back,
she realized,
she said work is not done yet.
Oh God.
I don't know if that's a real quote
that.
But she might've been tongue and cheek.
But here's the thing,
right?
Like you,
you,
you say things to.
And I do.
She might've very well just kidding.
She might've been joking around like
they might've been laughing,
she might've been done.
I guess my work is not done,
you know,
but then you see it flash in two
dimensions and who knows?
I think I was angry at her because she
didn't.
She said she didn't know who norm
Mcdonald was like,
fuck you.
You know who norm Macdonald.
Maybe she doesn't.
Maybe she really isn't in the comedy.
I mean she's not from around here.
Even those,
those people in that country that left
Africa,
they know who norm McDonald's.
Mcdonald's is a fucking genius.
Was on that boat growing coconuts.
I don't know man.
Don't norms.
Definitely a genius.
I missed the.
I can't get a human.
Must be on the podcast and someone could
put the Kibosh on him talking to people
anymore.
She mentioned Louis C k again and
possibly that he might mount a comeback.
I don't want to stop him.
She said it's worth just to see if he
does have an audience.
Of course you will.
There was 18 seconds left.
The interview tape.
It didn't expect to take a turn.
Ms Dot Gatsby of course had other ideas.
If he does have an audience,
then I won't be quoting standup.
Ms Dot Gatsby said,
quote me on that.
If Louis ck finds his audience,
I will definitely not quit standup
because my work here is not done.
Okay.
But then also,
could you say,
say I said that with a cheeky smile.
She added and left them.
Oh,
so she was.
She was fucking around.
Why does the New York Times still use
tape to record?
I don't know,
but I liked that she said that.
Say that I said it with a cheeky smile.
So good.
Like a little joke as we suspected she
was tongue in cheek,
like literally she sang cheeky smile.
So that's exactly what tongue and cheek
means.
The same thing.
Yeah.
So good for her.
Yeah,
man.
The shade do anything wrong.
It's not stealing.
Who Cares?
Anything transcribed can look fucked up.
Her Act,
all of it.
Like the animosity,
the fucking tension.
Who cares so unnecessary.
I have a couple of friends because
they're there.
A lot of Canadian comics by say by
saying that,
I mean against her.
That's what I mean.
I don't mean like her animosity towards
anybody else,
a Canadian comics generally they used to
come here to the states,
but like 10 years ago they start going
to England or Australia and I,
a lot of Canadian comics that knew her
and they were like,
she used to be really funny and I think
it was just this show.
There was like a more serious show.
So maybe in the interviews she just
fucking around pretending like she
doesn't know,
nor could be.
This is what she wants to do now to,
you know,
just because you're really funny for a
long time.
I mean,
I think that is something that I'm the
fuck is her name.
Someone is doing that now too.
She just did something where she,
she did an interview about it
that God dammit fuck is her name.
I got woken up real early this morning.
I'm super foggy.
My kid climbed into bed this morning at
5:00
AM,
they're going to go back to sleep.
She was,
um,
she's a constant.
She's a regular on the Howard stern
show.
She used to be really big.
She lost a lot of weight.
Got Her stomach stapled.
Very funny.
So is she called the scholarship?
The Queen of mean uh,
um,
the,
she used to do the and Lisa.
So Lisa Lampanelli is not doing standup
anymore because she's tired of hurting
people's feelings and she's going to
tell stories now.
Yeah,
she loves him.
Kind of shared or talk about it.
She loves.
So she,
she,
she changed what she does,
which is fine.
Like you should be allowed to change
what you do is it always made me feel
bad about my reaction,
my reaction to that with like,
fuck.
And then what you said.
So right.
That was like,
fuck.
All my reactions are always.
Well,
here's the thing,
he thinks about it.
You got and you have a brain.
You gotta know who the real enemies are.
Otherwise you'll waste all your venom on
the fake ones.
You don't want to want to save your
venom for the real,
real entities so that everybody else you
could make the like this.
You could make peace with it.
You don't need this.
There she is.
Bam.
Storyteller.
So she called her.
What does it say?
Shrink that shit down.
So I can read her heading sugar down
storyteller.
Yeah,
there it is.
Workshop leader inspiration to millions.
Well he got a little crazy there.
I think she's just gone crazy.
Yeah.
She might be gone.
He's lost her fucking mind.
Or She's enjoying herself.
Free expression.
She got a lot of fans and she's happy.
Anson just wearing a hoodie.
I don't want to hear that,
but she looks very different.
It's strange.
It's called Pilsen biomat.
The pharmaceutical.
Different book she's doing.
Yeah.
She's not been fun,
man.
Good for her.
Good start on her show and a storyteller
show.
It's hilarious.
I don't think it's going to be that
different to what she used to do because
you know,
people evolve,
people change and that's normal.
Like there's nothing sadder than seeing
a comic you saw 20 years ago and then
you see them again this year and it's
the same fucking shit.
So it's good that she have the same act.
Really Sad.
That's really sad.
Sealer guy from like the nineties.
It's still around and they haven't.
They literally have written a joke.
Yeah,
there's.
Those guys are real.
All right.
We see them guys are scary.
There was some
land over these last night,
the journal Roast battle before there
was a Jeremiah Watkins did a thing about
ads comic that it was the best.
It was so funny.
It was his thing on the Internet that
were were when you did a killed Tony
that he comes out as.
You think he's a funny dude
tonight that stand up on the spot.
She.
Okay.
Oh,
it's him.
It's his show.
Yeah.
He used to call it thunderpussy for a
little while.
I don't know why.
I think that was Brian.
I think Brian decided to call it
thunderpussy.
Voted on name.
I believe better name.
Democracy should stick with that name.
That's what thunderpussy is a way better
name.
Stand up on the spot.
You're so literal,
you know,
but the problem with Thunderpussy is
people might not know what it is,
but if they should,
why don't they know.
I'll figure it out.
Two hundred plus posts is the way to do
it.
Yeah.
Jeremiah listened to me during my vendor
pussy.
Yeah.
He should bring thunderpussy back.
What is this name?
Stand up on the spot branding side.
How about call it standup comedy right
on the spot?
No,
no,
no.
Stand up on the spot stand.
Standup comedy right on the spot right
now.
That's the name of the title.
No,
thunderpussy.
Bam.
We're done here.
Right.
But he did do a good impression.
We know guys like that who are these
comics,
didn't even,
etc.
It's just,
I don't want to call them comics.
It's just been the same thing for 20
years and they're open microbes for 20
years almost right in the go around
doing maybe an opening spot somewhere
and it's the same act,
so they'll have references In there of
stores that don't exist anymore and it's
so weird when you watched them do it,
you're like,
well what am I is this is a train wreck?
Is this sadness weekend for those in,
in smaller markets,
like montreal is a fairly small market
on the english side because there's so
many french people and even like the
end,
there's no money to be made in Canada.
So there are a lot of [inaudible] hacks
and comics and in montreal it's a
comedy.
Works stIll around.
It burned down like a couple months ago.
An amazing club that was down.
Yeah,
that would have been.
It was suspicious apparently.
I don't know the details,
but from what I understand,
they're going to rebuild the building.
They're going to break its legs.
Hopefully they're jimbo fucking took
off.
Jimbo.
Uh,
he,
he sold it.
His mom died and then he sold it or he
just closed it down.
He,
he,
yeah,
he closed it down than someone reopened
it a few months later under the same
name.
A couple of people that bought it that
love the club and they reopened it up
until when it burned down.
And do you remember ian?
He was,
the bartender said ian got a partner.
He opened it up.
And jimbo.
Jimbo was such a good guy.
Fucking love jumbo,
but he closed that club like a fucking
piece of garbage.
He didn't tell anyone.
He didn't tell his staff.
He just fucking.
They showed up one night and they were
like,
okay.
Oh,
the club fucking,
everything's taken out of the club.
He just left.
Yeah,
it must have been drunk.
Yeah.
Because you,
you use the.
I remember the first time I saw you was
there?
Yeah.
I used to do all the time.
And you were like,
and this wasn't like in fucking like
1984 or whatever.
I'm started going back that late.
But uh,
you were,
you were doing like big,
big,
big fucking rooms,
but you were there just to do a show
for,
you know,
for the clubs.
Work for jimbo forever.
So I'd come back and work for free.
Uh,
did,
did a weekend for him for free once I
just said,
just pay for my hotel.
I go,
let's just have some fun.
I just,
I just always loved being.
He's just,
he was such a great guy.
I'm sure.
Sure he's alive if he hears this still
us.
But he's a great guy and I just enjoyed
being around him and I was a struggle.
There was a small room,
it didn't have that many seats and he
had two floors in a nice little bar
downstairs and a pool table.
Then upstairs real intimate room.
it was just a great place.
And to me it was um,
it,
that place helped me.
It was um,
in the time when I started doing it was
right when my career went from being
like a middle act who was kind of going
on the road and doing these weird little
gigs to becoming a headlight or getting
on television.
All that happened.
A lot of it happened while I knew him
and during that time.
And so I've taken quite a few trips up
to montreal for the comedy festival to
work at jimbos place and she'd go back
and forth and do a bunch of gigs up
there.
It just was a,
it was an important spot for me,
you know,
like jimbo was one of those guys that he
had a real eye for.
Like he,
he booked everyone before they were
famous.
This is for people listening.
This is like a 85,
maybe 90 seat room,
like it's super small.
Yeah,
probably.
Maybe.
Maybe it stopped 100 maybe,
but he could have dumped him in there,
but he never asked.
Saw richard?
Jenny there,
dude.
Yeah.
Did you ever see jenny there?
I saw chris rock there.
I saw ray romano there guys.
I saw chris rock there as well.
Um,
I saw richard.
Jenny wants just level that place.
It was during a time where I was um,
I might've been like four years into
comedy.
I was,
I was pretty new in the comedy and I was
up there with you during the festival.
You were just there?
I was doing the festival.
Okay.
Yeah.
Maybe I'll add maybe five years,
maybe was five years into comedy and uh,
richard jenny was a monster man.
He,
he is the one guy that I just repeat
this over and over again because I don't
think people appreciate how fucking
funny he was because he was,
he was kind of an odd guy who was just,
it was hard to find like a category
where you fit it in.
But he was so fucking funny and he just
lit that place on fire and I remember
leaving his set going,
god damn,
it was terrible,
terrible.
But I absorbed something from it and one
thing was that that guy exhausted
subjects like he would take a premise
and exhausts that premise and smash it
to the point where when he was on like
this third wave of observation and
punchlines,
you would just like,
you were in awe of the fact that he was
continuing to beat down the subject as
you were the writing and the punchlines.
It was also like the mastery,
his ability just master a premise and
just just,
just dominate all the and take you off
guard,
catch you off guard.
But you also agreed while he was saying
it,
he was a wizard man.
I mean it's just sweet tight jokes,
man.
He was so god damn good.
That's how I am with ralphie may.
Like when I remember ralphie up,
I've never seen anyone get laughs.
Like ralph,
he got like,
he,
I get a series of shows with them like a
year or two before he died.
And the,
the walls felt like they were fucking
shaking like I could I go,
like I was hosting the show and he was,
he was closing it and he wasn't supposed
to close at first.
But then he,
he was like,
it was gone too good.
They,
they had to make them close closing.
Before that,
it was a,
I forget who it was.
There was a,
I forget who was in America.
Uh,
no,
this was in montreal.
The nasty show at just for laughs.
I forget if it was jimmy carr or it was
a brad williams one or the other,
but they,
the end,
whoever it was,
whether it was brad or,
or jimmy said the first night they were
like,
he should fucking clothes.
Like he's got a close and every night I
go in the room just to feel the energy
of that room.
And since I'm from like,
like I've been living in montreal for 20
years.
I know that fucking room.
I've seen like marilyn manson in that
real club soda.
No,
it's a metropolis.
Like I've been in that room.
Yeah.
I didn't ready room and that.
And if felt like the fucking walls were
shaking,
it felt like the way when you were
describing the earthquake,
that's how fucking ralphie
seen diaz kill.
Here's enjoyed ideas.
Kill.
I've never,
I've never been seen joey life.
Oh dude.
How long you in town for a.
We're leaving tomorrow.
Well,
if joey goes up tonight at the store,
I don't know if he's up.
That was a life changing thing.
He's the funniest guy I've ever seen.
Yeah.
I've never seen anybody killed.
Harder than joey diaz.
Never have to see it.
Okay.
If you think.
I mean ralph,
he was a funny guy.
Joey diaz is a force of nature.
It's a different thing.
This is not taking anything away from
ralphie round.
Ralphie,
I'll fuck you up.
Joe rogan.
Jody.
Jody is a different thing,
man.
He'll,
he'll make you just go,
whoa.
What?
Cocaine.
That's comedy too.
Shit.
I fucking love listening.
Joe.
Like I've never met him.
But I love listening to him.
He sounds like he sounds like him.
That's what I loved about when I met him
the
first time.
I was like,
you sound like a,
like an old gangster.
Like you sound like,
I love guys that sound like they should
be in fellas.
Yeah,
he definitely sounds like that.
Yeah.
Well he's,
he's legitimately seen more life and
more chaos than probably any random
thousand people.
Yeah.
He's got great stories.
New stories,
man.
He brings up new.
I've known the guy forever and I'll have
them on the podcast,
you know,
every few months.
And he has a new store.
I'm like,
how the fuck is this possible man?
And he's not a liar.
People are making sure doors.
No,
he doesn't.
I've met people.
They verify the stories.
He just lived a fucking insane life,
you know.
And you can tell when people make up
their stories.
Fuck,
he's not a bullshitter.
Yeah,
no,
he's not.
He's hilarious though.
It's um,
you know,
it's beautiful job,
man.
We get lucky.
Get to meet some really fascinating
people.
We do.
Yeah.
So when did you guys start doing this
show and compound media?
We started doing it about a year ago and
we started doing the free show about
four months ago because we like,
um,
we want to get people to listen to the
compound media.
How does compound media work?
Because compliment media,
you need to be a subscriber to the
whole.
The whole net were much.
Does it cost?
It costs eight 95,
eight $95 a month.
Us and good.
How many shows you get a anthony kumi
show up monday to thursday.
You get in hot water.
That's an amazing show.
It's a ehrenberg gino biscotti.
Four days a week.
You get about like 30 or 40 shows.
Yeah,
there's quite a few shows.
I met one of the hosts shoes on.
Well,
joanna.
Yeah.
So it was,
yeah,
she was on morning with bill schultz.
Joanna,
she's the one.
She's the,
she's the only female hosts that we have
on the network.
This is his new book yet this is um,
this,
uh,
there's something amazing,
better anthony columbia.
Like he,
like,
uh,
in the old days with opie and anthony,
he was like,
he helped out a bunch of young comics
and he's trying to,
I think that that's kind of what he's
doing with compound media and I'm
calling myself a young comic even though
I'm a young 45 and I'm going to die in
four months.
But well,
you mean people that are unestablished
young comics?
Yeah.
It takes people that are established but
funny.
And he said he started doing things
like,
like I'm,
I'm still based out of montreal and we
were the only show that all the shows,
they do them in his studio in manhattan.
And then he,
uh,
he asked me,
do you want to do this?
And I didn't want to move to like go.
I got my wife,
I got my life in montreal.
I like montreal.
So I was like,
no,
I'm going to montreal.
But then he was like,
do it.
If you do the show,
you can do it from montreal.
And plus I,
I.
How'd you do it?
How do you have it set up?
We have a studio in a,
in a,
like a,
a park acts which is a neighborhood with
where he's from.
I don't tell people where you are,
bro.
They're going to attack us.
So he said,
but he has a studio and it,
we do this show every week and it's,
it's a lot of fun.
Cool.
So you just do,
they downloaded,
do you send it,
upload it to send it to them?
It doesn't stream,
live,
not.
We were the only show that isn't live
and we never pretended like advantage of
that.
And do like weird splices where you go
back in time and change clothes.
Don't say a word about it.
Well fuck is happening here.
Just change your tee shirt because I
just saw this gentlemen just shows 100
percent law.
That should be your joke call.
You should call your show 100 percent
live.
I think the thing that people like
because all of our fans are like old,
uh oh.
And a fence.
And I think what people like is our show
is not political at all.
And the like,
a lot of the stuff on competent media
is,
is political and like people that,
like politico,
even people that like political stuff
after awhile they're like,
okay,
I get it,
I get it.
Hillary's a cunt.
Can we laugh?
And that is both.
The compound media is like very right
wing,
right?
There's no.
Is there any left wing like reno in the
background?
Yeah,
we should get,
we should get it like a trends third mic
hold trans show.
Yeah.
No,
no,
but it's not as right wing as people
think it is.
Well,
you know anthony's right wing,
but he's intelligent.
He's good,
sensible arguments whether you agree
with them or not,
you know,
I'm not necessarily right wing at all.
And uh,
I liked talking to him and he's super
funny.
That's one thing that people,
it's almost like in 2018 people have
forgotten like what?
And I see this on the right.
Two people on the left field.
Shit on anthony or people on the right.
Oh shit.
On like a.
I like comics and I'll be like,
that's funny.
That's funny.
Like even if that's not how you think.
That's funny,
right?
Like sarah silverman,
a lot of people on the right.
Shit on sarah silverman.
Sarah silverman is fucking funny.
She's hilarious.
Very funny.
Common.
But you know what man,
they only with their shitting on.
There's only her political opinions.
It's just,
it's a nonsense war to get into,
you know,
do you do what do you want everybody to
think to what you think,
you know?
And again,
it goes back to what we're talking about
earlier,
people just get on these teams and they
want to hate everybody's on the team and
she's on team left,
so fuck that bitch.
And that's what happens.
That's probably the why we got to the
top of the food chain that we grew up
together and a operation and then we
just,
okay,
well it's us versus them,
so we're going to win.
Yeah.
One hundred percent.
I'm william von hippel guy was on my
show last week,
wrote a book called the social leap.
Yeah,
I listened to that episode,
but the book is essentially all about
how human beings really succeeded by
figuring out once we were some sort of
weird primate thing that was close to us
by banding together and working in
cooperation and that,
uh,
forming teams and
loyalty to the teams always rewarded.
I mean,
this is what you're seeing in politics.
You should see in social circles.
Even when you know with these crazy
auntie for people and,
and proud boys.
It's all the same thing.
It's just tribal behavior.
You're seeing tribal behavior on the
right from the proud boys tribal
behavior on the left from antifa and
everybody else is the enemy and they
lash out and you know,
most of it is just completely misguided.
Most of all the aggression and the
violence and the hate is so stupid and
so misguided and counterproductive and
even though they think like,
because in the moment it's such an
impulsive,
childish thing to do with a lash out and
hit someone with a bike lock or punch
someone sucker punch them,
but you,
all you're doing is feeding this fucking
machine.
It's never going to run out of fuel.
It's just going to keep chewing up our,
our culture.
It's going to just keep going.
It's your,
you're not going to end it.
You're not going to.
If you start punching people,
it keeps it.
You're feeding the beast.
Yeah,
they're going to punch back.
They're not going just going to punch
back when they're going to kill you.
There's a thing.
I used to do a lot of shows for,
like,
I'm uh,
um,
the people that liked me are generally
men.
Like most of my fans are more men than
women.
So I used to,
whenever I do corporate gigs,
the only corporate gigs I'd ever do,
we're shows for military police officers
or the hell's angels.
And now every time.
And the thing I realize is when you talk
to a group of cops or you talk to a
group of hell's angels,
they're the same fucking guys,
the same guys because they got the same
exact fucking mentality through their
group.
The guys that are like,
okay,
it's us versus them.
We do this.
I,
right bro,
we're doing this,
we're doing this.
We're going in there and only difference
is you can call the cops.
No,
come here.
You just want to share.
Going to help me.
Well,
you're friends with him.
You called a friend.
I had a hotline.
You can call it like motorcycles rumble
up and take care of your problem.
The I got into this uh,
thing.
Uh,
about 15 years ago back home I did a
joke about it.
I did a joke on one of the galleries
for,
for the festival and uh,
a reporter talk shit about me.
And,
and it was a joke.
All my jokes are about little kids.
So it was.
No,
it was a joke.
I done a joke that I mentioned a little
girl that got kidnapped in my joke.
And the joke is good.
Yeah.
Fuck you always make me feel bad.
I'm going to give up comedy.
I fucking went out.
Joe rogan to give up comedy.
sorry.
I should commit suicide.
Me a hilarious joke about the little
girl victim.
Go ahead a jump because it'd be a bit of
vet the little girl,
but it was a.
And the joke is going to suck now
because it wouldn't have to explain the
joke,
but it was a because I owed money to the
government,
the irs,
the canadian irs,
and uh,
they seized all my accounts and I had
this little story and uh,
and that was the punchline was like,
they're fucking crazy.
If you owed them $8,
they're going to kidnap your kids.
They're the one that,
they're the ones that have blah,
blah,
blah.
And then name the little girl.
And now I've got a,
got a nice laugh.
And then it ended,
ended my set with a.
I got a standing ovation and the gala
got good reviews.
Everything was good.
Then like three weeks later,
this reporter guy writes a,
uh,
an article about how the audience was
shocked and offended.
And I was like,
they were shocked and offended.
I got a standing ovation and they were
shocked and offended.
And then there was this a french
canadian guy that's like a,
like a Larry King type guy.
He started his show.
He was like,
Mike Ward made fun of this little girl,
let's call her grandfather to see what
he thinks about that joke.
So he called the grandfather during the
show,
during the show.
He didn't tell the guy who's so.
He was like,
hey,
uh,
do you know Mike Ward?
And the guy was like,
yeah,
he made fun of a,
your granddaughter and this girl fucking
got kidnapped.
Like he was like,
well,
what do you think about that?
He was like,
well,
that's not cool.
Yeah,
no I have it isn't cool.
And then people lost and then people
were calling in,
go like a fucking asshole.
What a piece of garbage and then people.
So you've got an issue.
People lost that.
I like make them fun.
The little kids,
people lost their fucking minds and then
people were sending messages to my
manager that they knew where I lived.
They were going to murder me.
And then I look outside the house and my
manager calls me.
He's like,
there are people that are going to kill
you.
And I was like,
they're not going to kill me.
I look at my house.
I see fucking people lined up outside of
my house.
I'm like,
oh fuck,
I'm gonna get murdered.
But lIke I was looking at them and they
weren't attacking the house.
They were just like in front of my house
looking at my house and I was,
I'm not a brave dude.
Like I can't,
like,
like I'm not fucking you,
like I don't know how to fight.
So,
but I was like,
I'm just going to go talk to them to see
what the,
what the fuck's up.
So I went out and then they acted like
they were just regular guys just hanging
out outside my house.
I was like,
what the fuck?
And then I found out like two or three
years ago that I had done a couple shows
for hell's angels and the hell's angels
had parked.
They told their dudes like Mike Ward,
there are people that want to kill Mike
Ward.
So,
so watch the people that want to kill
Mike Ward.
So the with the hell's angels,
like on my house is in the middle of the
street people,
the other side of the street and on each
corner that were hell's angels watching
the people.
I was like,
fuck the hell's angels protected me.
it's wacky.
Yeah.
A lot of hell's angels are probably good
guys there.
They're like,
you're saying they're probably the same
as the guys with the crops gang if you
like.
And this is the same with mafia guys.
If you don't owe them money,
they're good guys.
They're good guys here with a message
that's your business that's like,
they're all like,
like whenever,
whenever I meet anyone,
like in the mafia or whatever,
I'm like,
that doesn't seem like he's in the mafia
is a good guy,
but I don't own like $19,000.
Right,
right.
Yeah.
Well i'M sure a lot of organized crime
and a lot of organized business,
they probably behave pretty similar.
Yeah,
because it's a business.
Things they can get away with and things
that they can't.
Yeah,
you can.
If you just go around,
go around breaking legs and killing pill
you then they'll kill your kids.
Goddamn business.
Goddamn goddamn goddamn business.
Alright gents.
Let's wrap this pitch up.
Doing this forever.
Um,
but uh,
when do you think this thing's going to
get resolved with the thing that's
weird.
Like when I went to court,
this have fucking stupid I am.
I thought it'd be like oj that at the
end of my,
my trial they'd be like case stand up
and we go,
we vote for you.
But in Canada they,
we get the verdict like for six or eight
months later.
So I'm going back to court early january
and then I'll probably get the verdict
in a year or two.
Like it's really like I'm going to be 97
by the timE I get the money is just cost
costing you so far.
It's going to cost me like,
like I said,
bruce from the like it's going to cost
probably 200,000,
210 and this is the thing I want to
start a.
I just paid off 20.
I could have paid off,
I could have paid off 10 times if I
wanted to,
but here's the thing,
what I want to do,
I was really lucky that a,
and I'm a guy that always sees the glass
half full,
but uh,
I,
I was lucky that I had the money to pay
this because if I was a guy,
like there was three or four years into
comedy and someone sent me a letter to
say,
hey,
you owe 80.
I would have fucking either committed
suicide,
quit comedy,
or four years into comedy you'd probably
be more inclined to say something
inappropriate because you thought it was
funny.
Yeah,
it'd be shocking.
Yeah.
Right.
Like you get rewarded what,
especially when you do open mic nights
and you're just starting out,
you get rewarded in taking chances that
aren't necessarily Funny,
but there are shocking.
Yeah.
You're risky because it might be the
best reaction of your set.
It's not.
Might not even be necessarily good,
but it's the best reaction of your set
because frankly your set is mostly dog
shit,
right when you're two or three years in.
Right?
Yeah.
So imagine that gets on the internet
some three year old comic is barely
stage legs under him dropping bombs.
Just saying something stupid that you
think you're going to be funny.
Yeah,
I'd want to.
I want to start a thing though.
I haven't started yet because I was gone
through the depression.
I've been talking about this for years,
but now since I'm not in my depression
I'm going to start a fund for whoever
the next guy or next girl,
next woman is going to go broke so
they're going to be a storm of them.
But I think because uh,
because uh,
like,
like I was lucky I think of myself as
lucky for real cause like I don't have a
lot
of money but I had enough money to
defend myself and I didn't even have to
go like,
ah,
fuck it in any way.
Raise your profile to help you.
It would have helped me if I didn't
spend all my days in the bathtub crying,
drinking wine.
Like,
like if,
if I had used this,
I could've,
I could've.
I don't know if I would have become like
super famous,
but I could have used this,
but I was like,
I didn't,
I didn't want to use this.
I didn't want to be.
I didn't want to be the guy that made
fun of disabled children
too late.
I don't know.
yeah,
I get it,
man.
I mean,
I think that's a real noble idea to,
to,
to start a fund for the next guy and
especially because Canada has such a
wonky system.
Canada,
you're,
you're basically conneCted.
We're all together.
We were.
You guys were right here.
Yeah.
Basically Vermont with crazy last 11
human rights commissions because there's
the canadian human rights commission and
every canadian province has their human
rights commission and there in the world
there are 12 human rights commission,
so there's the one at the hague that
they go after evil war criminals and
shit and then they're a leaven in Canada
that go after open milkers and Jordan
Peterson and they go after me.
I think
thiS is.
We can make comparisons to what they're
doing with free speech to what we deem
to be the real issues with controlling
free speech on the internet.
I think there's real similarities.
I think having these human rights
councils,
committees,
people getting together and decide and
they don't want to come off callous or
ruthless or you know,
and so they can decide,
well that's gone too far.
This is wrong.
You shouldn't be able to say that.
That is the number one problem with
controlling free speech.
Like you should be able to say whatever
you want and then if people don't like
you,
then they'll watch you or they don't go
see you and you let the free market
decide.
It's not about.
We're not talking about inciting,
hey are saying you should go kill
people.
One of the things that a lot of people
had a problem with with gavin was gavin
was actually saying punch them.
Hit them.
That's fucking crazy because he's not
used to being punched and hit.
That's what it is.
People that are around violence a lot,
don't just willy nilly advocate
violence,
you know,
and I think he realizes that's probably
why he stepped down from this whole
thing now because he realizes like,
oh,
it's probably hard to see how you're
perceived when you're in that fucking
polarizing a position as he is that he
just was at one point in time.
The guy who was one of the cofounders
advice.
It's really kind of weird,
interesting provocate tour guys.
Very smart.
I enjoy talking to him,
to this guy who's like,
all right,
and you know,
the leader of a hate group.
Like what?
That shit sticks to you man.
Yeah,
I mean that's.
It sticks to you like crazy glue.
Yeah.
I don't always going to do,
but I think what we were saying earlier,
it's like that perceptions,
some sometimes
almost as important as reality and in
your case may prove to be until wore
off,
right?
Yeah.
Like now I'm it people forgotten and
people see the thing that,
that,
like I said,
when we were starting out the podcast,
the thing that kind of pissed me off is
like in America,
I like that.
And in quebec,
which is french Canada,
they saw me as a guy that that would.
I do jokes,
but I'm,
I'm offensive,
I'm a fucking dirty comic and I do what
I do and I think I do well.
People enjoy that kind of comedy and
they were.
They enjoyed gangster rap the same way.
They enjoy violent movies.
I'm not like some shitty like fucking
open mike are doing rape jokes that
don't work.
If I do rape jokes,
my rape jokes,
fucking murder,
rape jokes,
kill.
Like I've won like fucking 15 awards.
Every rape,
rape joke of the year award,
but,
but people,
people like a lot of the media instead
of going,
there's something weird about the
government because the government
judging my case is exactly like judging
a movie.
It's like saying fucking why?
Why are they driving so fast and fast
and the furious why they forgot that
what I do,
even if you don't like what I do is art.
Yeah,
and you,
you might not think standup is art,
but it is,
it's a fucking expression.
And I were talking about this earlier
that it just seems too much like you're
just talking cause cause here's the
thing.
Whenever you see a comic that that's
good,
it looks easy and when it looks easy it
looks like they just,
it's off the top of their head and
that's what they think.
And that's a thing.
I think it was jim jefferies that said
this,
that he said there are things that I
think and there what I sound stage or
things that I think are funny and that's
what we do on stage.
Like it.
It's not a check.
That was me too.
Those are my specials are exactly the
same.
Probably you.
All right.
So jim jeffries.
But it's.
Everybody says that he had a fucking
good bit about vegan.
Catsa was awesome.
When can people watch your show?
Oh they can see it.
I'm on amazon prime in the us and uk.
Uh,
the stand up show.
Yeah,
it's called.
It's called a Mike Ward.
Infamous.
And my first 15 minutes are about my
court case.
It's a really good special.
I'm super happy with this special.
It's the exact opposite of nanette.
So amazon prime is amazon prime when lot
of standup,
right?
It's like the retarded version of
netflix.
Where let you say retarded.
Yeah,
they let me say retired.
I was on the phone right now.
What did he say?
So in three weeks I'm going to be on.
I'm going to be on hulu.
Yeah,
very liberal.
They have handmaid's tale.
You're fucked.
If not.
We were a,
were a friday,
friday four to six
on compound media.
Doesn't gavin's still have a show on
like crt tv or some crtc crtv?
Yeah.
What is it still hasn't yet?
He still has it.
I,
I've already talked to gavin in like
over a year,
like a.
And the last time he wrote me he wrote a
funny,
like I thought it was.
He wrote this weird fucking thing that I
could tell that he was drunk and I was
like,
no way.
He wrote me like a four in the morning,
some fucking random thing and I was
like,
I'm happy to see you're drinking again.
And then he wrote something,
stopped drinking for awhile.
He had stopped drinking for awhile and
then he wrote something like almost
insulting me and that I wrote,
ha ha ha.
And then he wrote a,
you're too hard to.
You're too hard to piss off.
I'm going to write someone else.
So he was just,
he was an a plus my,
since my name is ward,
like I was probably like at the end of
the list,
so he had to call some guy named.
Some manco are going through all of his
different fucking contexts,
contexts.
And that's funny.
Yeah.
All right gentlemen,
thanks for being here,
man.
Fight.
Thank you Canada.
Get your goddamn shit together when it
comes to freedom of expression.
This is nonsense.
You silly goose geese.
Call the most amazing country.
Other than that,
so nice up.
There it is.
Fucking free speech in line.
Alright,
bye everybody.